the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
crazy openings led to Wild results at
the U.S Juniors and Senior championships
in St Louis with precious points up for
grabs chasing players put pressure on
the leaders Alice Lee is unflappable
responding with near perfect moves to
win a hard-fought battle against Carissa
Yip to remain atop the standings Arthur
guao was quietly stealing the show in
the Juniors defeating co-leader Andrew
Hong to claim sole lead despite drawing
his game melocation looks to be
Untouchable after playing the tournament
of his life to maintain clear first in
the senior section only two rounds
remain with titles on the line day eight
of amazing chess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
of the US Juniors and Senior chess
championships we're here in front of the
world famous Santos chess club the
tournament is heating up and we are on
the final stage of it let's go to the
studio and follow the action
[Music]
we are in the final stages of the 2023
junior girls juniors and seniors
championships this is the penultimate
round and our coverage from the St Louis
chess club begins now
[Music]
hello everyone happy Sunday I'm woman
Grandmaster Katrina name Tova and I am
here with Grandmaster Yasser Sarah one
okay Championship rounds coming up it's
been terrific hasn't it yeah incredible
games and I think we can even expect
more battles today oh no question about
it as yesterday some very very key
challenges and our leaders met them one
Alice Lee up against her rival Carissa
Yip she performed magnificently Under
Pressure even won the game Alex at with
the black pieces also Big Challenge
against kaidana draw and Arthur wow he
came out of nowhere
and leads the tournament Kate do the
honors tell us about the standings let's
start with the girls yes so take a look
at the standings after round seven we
have a soul eater Alice Lee just
cruising through this term and fantastic
performance with six points clear second
Zoe tank five phones and five points and
third place through Yankee and with four
points I like the pawns uh tell us about
the junior standings did you notice it's
not that close we I mean it's not that
clear there is Arthur go with Five
Points closely followed by uh Brandon
Jacobson abimayo misra two-way tie for
the second place and at the Legends how
are the legends doing here we again have
a soul eater of fantastic performance so
far by Malik satkachian with six points
Alex Chapel of clear second four and a
half points and a two-way tie for the
third place Vladimir kopian and Gregory
kaidanov and tell us about the format
for these three National Championship
tournaments right so we have a 3-10 play
around Robin's which means each player
plays everyone else in their respective
tournament the time control is classical
chess 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
followed by 30 minutes for rest of the
game and there is a 30 second increment
from move one no draw offers allowed and
a traditional scoring system 1.4 win
zero half a point for a draw zero points
for a loss Kate remind me about the
playoff rules of two players tied for
first right so if there's a two player
tie for first we have a two game rapid
match 10 minutes plus two second
increment if they are still tight there
will be Armageddon and if there are more
players than two types right so more
than three players we still have a rapid
round robin 10 minutes plus two seconds
then if there are still tight we have
Blitz match or Blitz round robin with
three minutes plus two second increment
and it's still tight Armageddon is going
to decide to Championship we're running
out of road but tell us about the
schedule
schedule one round a day today round
eight tomorrow 1pm Central Time round
nine if necessary we will have playoffs
on Tuesday July 25th
Christian good to have you in studio as
always let's play the game what ifs
good to see you uh guys welcome back
chess fans to the final two championship
rounds here in St Louis we've had
amazing three tournaments and finally
we're going to see the conclusion of
these exceptional tournaments but let's
take a look at where the leaders stand
and what they need to do in order to
clinch the title in the next couple of
rounds and take a look at that man he's
focused he's ready to take on the
challenge and he could potentially be
clinching the title in today's round
take a look at that he's been having the
event of a lifetime six out of seven
absolutely incredible Stellar play if he
wins today he wins the tournament
outright if he draws and shabalo doesn't
win his game shabalov is one and a half
points behind then katyon wins the
tournament a lot of things can go right
for this man he has the white pieces
against one Patrick Wolf let's take a
look at that head to head as you can see
six points for a Grand Master Malik
sakachian only three points for Patrick
Wolf but this is deceiving because
Patrick started off very slowly half a
point out of three but in the last four
rounds I have to say two and a half out
of the four and yesterday's attacking
Masterpiece with the white pieces
definitely will be quite frightening for
Malik said big big clash in this one
let's take a look at what's happening in
the Juniors section well I have to say
that one is much tighter at the top as
you can see we have a soul leader our
tour guo just exceptional play all
throughout this event you see that
International Master he's not an
international Master he's a grand master
elect he's been having a stellar year as
well and he has the opportunity to
potentially win an incredibly
competitive national title and let's
take a look at the head to head as we're
going on in the eighth round and as we
can see abhimanyu Mishra the rating
favorite going into this event four and
a half points golden opportunity with
the white pieces taking on the
struggling Artur Azu who is also the
lowest rated player in this event so
Mishra will definitely be looking to
pounce in today's round and another big
Clash that I'm having my eyes on is of
course this one between Justin Wang and
Brandon Jacobson crucial Victory from
for Brandon yesterday with the black
pieces against another struggling
opponent that is Josiah steerman and
we've seen him he can win games with the
black pieces he's doubling that black
color and today has a golden opportunity
to potentially catch up with the leader
and speaking of the leader who will he
be facing today he's facing Jason Liang
two and a half points for Jason Five
Points as you can see for Arthur and
we've seen him on camera he's focused
and ready to take on the challenge Jason
Liang started off slowly in fact he was
the only player that did not score a
single half a point in the first three
rounds zero out of three but in the
second part of the event definitely
turning on the engines big Clash this
one is going to be and let's take a look
at what's happening in the junior girls
competition I have to say this is a tale
of one lady and one lady only and that
is Alice Lee what an incredible
tournament she's been having so far
potentially will be looking to win her
first U.S junior girls National Title
take a look at that she can clinch with
a victory the tournament today if Zoe
Tang doesn't win her game she is one
point behind Alice Lee and this is the
big Clash Alice Lee versus Iris move
with everything on the line will Alice
be able to clinch the title today well
we're going to find that out in the next
few hours guys we have amazing clashes
ahead of ourselves I cannot wait to see
what these players bring to the
chessboard thank you Christian and Kate
please do the honors and tell our
audience what they can expect of the
pairings let's start with the girls yes
we have a lot of amazing clashes here at
12 against prasanna Yen against mangalam
Lee against move very important match
you can clinch the championship title or
at least secure a place in the playoffs
tank against Yip another really
important game and work against Leo and
in the Junior
in the generous we have wank against
Jacobson hunk against tiermann we will
definitely be closely following that
game the same about Liang against guo
gazarian against agapati and Mishra
against Zoo Mishra has to win that's
just what it's come down to and tell us
about the senior parents in the seniors
loogie facing Navica Benjamin against
acopian gurevich against shabalov very
important game
Championship with this game and Ruth
against kaidanov and let's go to the
World Chess Hall of Fame as the players
are getting ready to do battle in these
Championship rounds round eight is
coming up see Joel Benjamin and Vladimir
kopian is their table ready to go
I'm sorry uh you're not coming in uh
Christian on my microphone I don't hear
you well
it will remediate that problem in just a
second and you did you did it well
um Alice Lee uh just uh what do you
think about this I believe this is her
fourth chance at winning the title but
she's never going to be a better
opportunity is very very close and you
know she is really kind of in her Zone
playing Just fantastic tournament very
good chest she's confident chest right
she's very very confident and after
yesterday's win I mean that is another
great boost to your confidence are you
beating a key rival uh Carissa Yip the
highest rated coming into the event by
the invitation we know that Alice is
since surpassed her with this great
summer that Alice is being having look
at this the tarash okay
I haven't seen that in a while I know it
usually see it from a different move
order not from this one
the problem is that if you do it like
this I can take on D5 and generally they
take on D4 that's whenever you see the
Knight on F3 and the Knight on F6 black
takes on D4 right that is considered to
be equalizing for uh for black she takes
on D4 but I think there's some options
right now I think you can go Queen to A4
first queen A4 check Queen A4 check take
on D4 after and then be recapturing the
pawn queen things before immediately
Knight C6 we're expecting and then I've
always called this the tarash Gambit the
tarash Gambit uh Knight C6 Queen D1 I've
had a couple of games I've taken the
pawn the subcompensation but uh it's fun
to watch uh let me just check in on the
game between Zoe tang and Carissa
because that one okay King's Indian yeah
uh Bishop E2 Bishop E3 kind of a
gligarich system
uh developing the Bishops you haven't
committed your Pawn to F2 F3 yet but
Knight C6
inviting uh the uh space grabbing move
D5 the Knight jumps to E5 F2 F4 and uh
what do you do here do you go back or do
you go ahead forwards uh Kate I would
try to go forward always forwards yes
possible you want with nights going
forward okay but there's always this uh
possibility that the Knight will get
booted into some really off the off the
Beaten Track right so uh this could be a
double-edged game in uh this position by
the way uh not sure if uh the the life
position there is up to date
Bishop E2
there's a beautiful cameras of uh the
board position great great pieces Knight
C6 okay and and let's go to
um Malik Set uh this game and see what
he's doing with Patrick wool
b2b3 okay we know Patrick
loves his
um night or uh Sicilian Bishop B5 it's
always
do you think of it as a moral Victory
when your opponent Dodges your prep or
is it annoying I sometimes I sometimes
believe it should be fire I think it's
it's an interesting variation to to try
for white and I like Malik's set up now
to kind of go to different lines with B3
yes Bishop B7 castles C4 oh maruti
structure Queen B6 this came a Christian
I'm deleting it this came quickly as if
this is a kind of a theory is it A6 is
by far the main line in the position no
Queen to B6 is quite an obscure sideline
A6 is one of them Rook to E8 is another
one Queen to B6 I think only six games
at least in my database have been played
with A6 there's more than 130 games so
quite a big difference definitely will
force magic set to take some time Ponder
his next move and
when he came after that brilliant
victory in the maruti structure but with
the black pieces facing the maruti
structure Bishop E5 Queen H4 exactly and
he said that he always liked to play uh
from the black side of the Marathi
structure not from the white side so now
maybe who knows Patrick might have heard
that either he decides to force uh Malik
said to play on the white side of the
morosi structure the interesting
strategies going on in this game I have
to say I love these opening uh battles
where they try to out Fox one another
let's just jump in on the game of
Douglas root and Gregory kaidanov the
reason I'm bringing that to your
attention is because again when I was
going through those Scholastics periods
all of these gambits the max Lang attack
the fried liver the Danish Gambit the
Evans game they're so fun they're so
much fun let's go C3 D take C3 be
okay let's go uh Danish he takes B2 now
obviously white is giving up material to
get a very very quick development and
what white is hoping to do is go castles
Queen B3 and with Black's King still
stuck in the center to take advantage of
that Bishop B for check developing with
the tempo Knight F6 castles and we're up
to date I'm going to say that we're in
the dusty part of the library on this
one a Christian but I don't think
today's players the modern chess players
go into this variation anymore I mean
when was the last time somebody in the
elite tournament chess has played this
yes I don't see it right I don't see it
I think Ervin Lami around 26 uh 50 rated
player played it
four years ago for exactly five years
ago in fact with the black pieces so
definitely not one of the main topical
lines for sure well Doug is definitely
trying to catch Gregory out uh here and
Kate uh your take at the moment I mean
it's I mean why does
it's like there's a little bit pushing
it for me but I really like the Bishops
are amazing uh and we are maybe even
threatening some E5 really fast oh no
question about it right if it was white
to move E5 is huge that's just actually
a killing threat uh if I play E5 and I
force this Knight to move uh it's over
so it's all about D6 or castles right
now if you if you Castle E5
um this is still looking uh awfully
dangerous you're gonna have to go 24.95
and I don't know it doesn't I I'm a
little bit worried I think it has to be
D7 D6 Christian uh I I mean it's it's
been
for me ages since I've studied this and
I haven't studied it with an engine at
all so you tell me what's uh not this
recommended not these six not decent no
no no you have to deal with that Knight
on C3 before you can lock the bishop
away from uh the center and the King
side with the six d695 I think is quite
problematic so what they do here is
either Castle either they just simply
take on C3 First Take on C3 is uh seems
to be the main line seems to be also the
engine is eval
but I have to say taking on C3 and
allowing this bishop to run free on the
long diagonal without an opponent on it
this doesn't feel like the right way of
doing things but how many pawns am I up
to a couple of them right right that's
pretty decent material advantage right
castle and then you have ideas of E5 98
or Knight to E4 the position is going to
be wild but definitely Douglas is saying
look I'm going to gamble a little bit
I'm going to risk it for a biscuit
because I haven't had a lot of
opportunities in this tournament but I
mean he's feeling good he had an amazing
game yesterday against Maxim loogie he
almost checkmated Maxim on uh on the
board he's feeling right he's confident
he wants to repeat what he did yesterday
and he's taking his chances all right
nice I just wanted to check in on
shabbalah for my pick against Dimitri
gurvich I mean shibalov's the only
person who's putting any pressure on
Malik said shebalov needs a win with
blacks he needs Patrick Wolfe to slow
down and he is a returning Champion
he has that kind of confidence that
maybe he can try again not too much and
not many moves have been played uh we'll
keep an eye on that one it's on a slow
boil let's go to the game between Jason
Liang and our tournament leader Arthur
go now coming on to the show we
mentioned that Arthur is a grand master
who select what that means is that he's
due to get his title he just doesn't
have it officially I didn't realize that
he was a gml like I hadn't picked him or
even thought of him as a favorite but
he's been very impressive he's having
amazing performance in this tournament I
agree and let's just see what he chose
again he comes in with a half a point
lead and what does he do he plays one of
the most risky and double-edged and
super sharp lines of the rui Lopez uh
this uh kind of a thought of it is the
the classical as well as a kind of an
archangel line in the rui Lopez h2h3 B5
both players kind of blitzing out their
opening moves I want to say as if this
is all very very standard for them
and they're still in a theory I want to
go back to the game of Alice Lee for
just a second because uh the the
no no no no he doesn't
like I am not going to share I refuse
you take it away
uh I was looking at the Juniors right so
I'll let you go with Alice just because
she's uh our leader sure and I'll come
back to this one uh so so this whole uh
Pawn sacrifice this tarash Pawn
sacrifice I know a little bit about it
because I've I've had to compete against
it let's put it that way and as um
Christian had mentioned here there's
actually two major moves the one Alice
chose and the other one is to play Czech
that's to provoke the bishop in the way
so that in this position your takes
takes takes uh we don't get hit with the
Knight C6 well what year after Queen D4
there's no more Knight C6 right exactly
if there's no more Knight C6 in the game
there's Knight C6 the queen drops back
and then after it takes white is
supposed to capture this uh on her
choice E2 E3
gives black what we would call an easy
game so if you stop and you just say
okay what has happened and you go okay
white who opens the game has developed
two units the Knight on C3 the bond on
E3 black who is supposed to be behind
white is a similarly developed two units
and it's Black's turn so after Knight F6
we would say black has an easy game she
she's not behind in development Knight
F3 is an isolated Queen Pawn uh you've
got lots of moves here Bishop D6 Bishop
C5 just to Adriel that point home maybe
you can show on your board the other
version with Knight F3 and Knight F6
included from the beginning before right
so C4 E6 so for example if we play
Knight F3 Knight F6 Knight C3 C5 takes
now black is at a Crossroads if you
capture and I capture there's no Knight
C6 tonight on F3 and once I take on D5
one of the main lines so you take on D4
I take on D5 right take on D4 first so
this is the tarash yeah and then this
one take on D5 but now you have Bishop
to G5 you can exactly get the bishop out
right in front of the pawns and then
only after play the move E3 a much
better version for uh White Knight C6
Queen D1 drops back and then I will be
able to take advantage of your weakness
on D5 the isolated Pawn so much better
version with the B Swansea one and look
Alice Lee doesn't have to take any
unnecessary risks right she's one point
ahead of her nearest competitor a draw
maybe it's not the end of the world by
any means right
well but she's having this uh remarkable
remarkable tournament uh point in the
lead white pieces
playing against the lower rated player
she's thinking I want to put my uh
Authority on this event Bishop B4 by the
way on the board yeah and this is also
the game of the youngest competitors in
the junior junior Champions as well 13
years old so wow young is playing each
other exactly Bishop B4 okay I would
probably play Bishop to D2 myself as
white followed by Bishop E2 in castles I
don't I'm not a big fan of allowing
Bishop take C3 myself okay we'll keep an
eye on this and now you can share with
us what you wanted to share Christian
there are some funny stuff going on in
the Juniors especially in this game of
Andrew Hong vs Josiah steerman and
Andrew is not that far behind the
leaders I believe he's one point behind
Arthur half a point behind the people
placed on a second position take a look
at this and we've been seeing this line
essay in this tournament quite a few
times in fact the karakan E5 C5 and now
Knight to F3 take on D4 and this queen
to F4 idea now there's not a lot of
games in this position the majority of
them 48 of them are with E6 which is by
far the main line but the funny aspect
of this position is that black has tried
E6 G6 and H6 these are the only moves
that have been played in this position
and guess what Josiah plays in this one
F6 this is a novelty say what yes he
played the move F6 a novelty at move
number six and this is what I was
talking about whenever I was saying that
the engines are not going to kill the
game of chess the engines in fact are
going to give us more and more
opportunity to explore early on in the
game and this is what Josiah seems to be
doing with this move F6 immediately
throwing The Gauntlet at say hey I
surprised you let's see what you got
over the board let's see how you handle
this position when there's a lot of
pressure in the center but take a look
at this I was looking through some
variations and I would say the most
critical comes after this move Bishop to
B5 just pinning the Knight on C6 and the
best move in the position is G5
this is some wild stuff where is the
queen going Queen to A4 potentially G4
Knight to D4 F takes E5 and the position
goes absolutely uh wild you take take I
take Bishop D7 you cannot take American
a because you lose the queen on A4
Knight C3 good luck assessing this
position
um I have no idea what's happening the
king is completely open but I do need
just a couple of moves to get it to
safety Knight F6 Bishop G7 E4 and D4 I
do have very powerful Center and um I
have to say if you don't know exactly
what you're doing in Josiah with the
black PC seems to hint at the fact that
he's analyzed this position at home you
know I would be quite worried so let's
see what um Andrew did he played the
move Knight to C3 in my estimation a
very natural move sure right and now we
see this move A6 on the board
now comes the big question and I don't
think we have any agenda uh
exactly and guess what whites move
White's main move in the position
okay
this is some funny uh business going on
to my eyes I think he's going to go
Bishop to D3 this seems like the most
naturalization and then the question
comes uh are you going to take on E5
this is the engine's recommendation and
then Knight to F6 and we play this
position my question is what if I just
simply Castle
E6 and I guess you're not really in time
to stop me from forcing this this Knight
to get exchanged on C6 once I do that
and I manage to fortify my Pawn uh my
central D5 Pawn then I'm going to start
feeling quite good with black pieces and
if I manage to Castle get the pawns
rolling down the board in the center I'm
going to be feeling quite good about the
position it's all about the king safety
if white manages to take advantage of
this early F6 weakening uh the king
challenging the center as early as move
six while he if he can manage to do that
and catch the king in the center then
he's going to be successful in this
position if it doesn't then black is
going to be perfectly fine
I have to say from psychological
perspective I like this for Josiah
Steven did you know he is not having the
greatest tournament he had a tough loss
yesterday while Andrew hung is still
fighting kind of for the lead so here
he's surprising him and Andrew really
has to fight and figure out what to do
about this whereas Josiah is just like
taking a risk and thinking like there is
pressure on Andrew not really on me at
the same time if you are Andrew and
you're one point behind the lead then
your opponent plays F6 like this you're
going to uh you know right this is what
you want too I mean mix it up let's uh
let's dance let's dance
um I just turning to the game of uh Zoe
for a moment against Carissa because
that was the big moment right here and I
wanted to say that if I was in Zoe's
shoes I it would be for me all about F4
I play the move F4 and I'd ask Carissa
if she wanted to move her Knight
forwards or backwards Zoe uh didn't play
F4 she said I'm more afraid than the
night would move forward h3e6 F4 and the
Knight went back to D7 so a little
gamesmanship going on in this opening
and uh something caught your eye case no
I'm just wondering so we have Knight F3
I like this one 65 yes right black is
kind of ready with the development now
so black wants to open the e-file
because the PS4 piled up on that file no
question about it and I'm assuming uh
that Zoe wants to recapture with the sea
Pawn rookie 8 makes a very natural
impression uh attacking the pawn on e4
now uh oftentimes you see benoni players
they like the setup with their Knights
on C3 and D2 so let me borrow a page
from the benoni uh remember Bobby
Fischer's Knight H5
maybe you want to go there I don't know
so I don't know if this is Theory or not
because again I think F4 is more
challenging than H3 here it feels like
black should be okay what about Knight
takes E4 is that a possibility oh have I
allowed it yes if I take with a knight
you'll take on C3 if I take with the
other night you'll play F5 right
is going to be hanging once you move no
question about it so let's continue
um you go Knight GIF ah Knight G5 and
then Knight E6 but you have Queen H4 all
the time
yes yeah oops
yeah this is not enough uh and another
way though and this is very interesting
I'm not 100 sure that this is a
compensation uh it's just like one of
those remember the attack yesterday that
Douglas root had against uh Maxim you
just take the Jeep on off the board
right you take a a little bit of the
King's Guard away and suddenly the black
king is very vulnerable here I don't
know if it's a full compensation or not
but by the way we do have e takes D5 C
takes D5 on the board but I'm with you
100 I think that for Carissa uh rookie
eight is absolutely crucial I just want
to throw out one strategic uh concept
here too is this move Knight C5
at first blush you look at that you go
oh
that looks wrong right like something
can't I just take take and this is one
of those variations where you can get
punished for over extending too soon you
know you've gone you've gone D5 and E5
and you expect your opponent to collapse
and suddenly you're looking over on the
king side and you're going
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
in Kingston in defense allow it to
pushed upon push them as far as you want
as you are losing time you know your
king is not castled yeah this is maybe
not in the best spot so I can try to
take advantage and then Bishop on G7
that can be a great diagonal no question
about it that that that's a deadly
Bishop on so uh the positions uh full of
intrigue and uh Christian back over to
you well what's happening with Balaji in
this one because he caught fire in the
last few rounds uh is he on a two-game
winning streak maybe three game winning
streak anyway he's looking to extend
that streak because take a look at this
one early on it seems like Kirk is in
big big trouble with the white pieces
you know let's change slav really what
Bishop to F4 take a look at this Knight
to E4 E3 everything standard so far G6
and now he overextended as you were
mentioning with the move C4 try and take
advantage immediately of the fact that
the pawn structure is a bit feeble in
the center with the spawn on D5
unprotected by another Pawn but the
problem is he completely missed this
move E5 and Balaji knew it this seems to
be some sort of a trap in the exchange
to love if you take first of all the
problem is that your Bishop cannot come
back to D2 so now I do we'll just simply
go Queen to A5 check you cannot cover
with a queen because Bishop to B4 is
going to finish the game in one motion
exactly thank you for your time and
you're going to go Knight to D2 but
Bishop to E6 followed by potentially
long Castle a lot of pressure is piling
up and Brewing on the D file this is
looking really bad in fact the engine is
saying this is completely losing for
white
so the only way to stay in the game is
to take take with the bishop F6 and now
go King to E2 I mean this one is looking
extremely dangerous I understand you're
still not busted by any stretch of the
imagination you will be able to play F3
King to F to hide the king there but I'm
looking at the assessment of the
position the objective assessment of the
position I'm also looking at the
Practical assessment of the position and
I don't see absolutely any problems for
black in fact it seems like the pawn on
C4 is the biggest weapon in the position
and it belongs to Black I'm only a few
moves from promotion and I'm going to be
able to support that pawn with the
bishop on A3 so this one is looking
really good for black I have to say and
by the way to get to this point where
maybe you're surviving you still have to
make some very precise moves and you
have to make some very precise decisions
as well because you can take with the
bishop you can take with the Knight you
can take with the pawn on fight so big
big problems and take a look where they
stand right now Bellagio on four points
right I think he started with half out
of two or something along those lines he
definitely started with a loss against
Arthur Zoo right so fighting is without
an encouraging sign but he uh pulled
himself up and then this is what is
happening right now with another Victory
he could get actually close to the
leadership position if not maybe even
equalizing the leader and he's played
yeah Knight takes E5 as you okay that's
a good start for Kirk yes I I just have
to say I some somehow it's very funny to
look at the game of Douglas root and
Gregory kaidanov because you'd almost
think that these are the junior players
as their gambling sacrificing away but
guess what happened uh we left it
exactly at this moment and we asked the
question well what should black do
should black play D7 D6 castle and a
Christian prescribed Bishop take C3 pair
currently D6 Knight D5 is not the way
you want to go as black and Castle's E5
gets you into all kinds of trouble so
Bishop takes Bishop takes castles sorry
Knight G5 so we were kind of talking
about E5 pushing that pawn by 95 is
another strong button attacking of seven
we're we have ideas of f4 and E5 well
guess what H6 what are you doing I'm
sacrificing what are you doing I'm
taking
I'm taking and I pushed the pawn that
was my initial idea and check this out
after Knight E8 F4 the players are
playing like this is all
super standard stuff and and it it may
well be a Christian as as
Barry got any players gotten here before
this is not standards this is not
standard no F4 is seems to be some sort
of a novelty F4 right here yes uh what
had previously is dog on one hour and 35
minutes on his clock and look at Doug Go
I mean these are some really tough
decisions so F4 DC must know something
exactly right I mean he has one hour 35
minutes so hello not wasting any time
he's gaining time by playing these moves
so if I gave you this position and said
okay study it and you tell me what you
would do with white
I don't think even after a 20-minute
reflection you would find the move E6
maybe a few hours later and and figuring
things out but he played the move E6 a
la Tempo so I
to me that's absolutely absolutely clear
Doug has prepared this oh yes absolutely
what's going on it seems like first of
all came to G8 or Bishop takes E6 I'm
not sure about King to f8 King to f8
works as well but Queen to H5 already
seems to be quite dangerous uh Bishop
takes C6 at least to my eyes is the main
thing automation yeah you have to play
it if you allow the move F5 even look I
mean I understand you have two pieces
for The Rook that's probably an
advantage right material advantage but
when I see this couple of Pawns I mean
so close to promotion so close to my
king right I really don't like it so I'm
not going to accept this right I'm going
to take on E6 and the question is he
will start calculating this will he find
the best moves and take a look how
difficult this is I go F5 right you drop
back on D7 let's say right I give you a
check or
I can go F6 as well F6 and now there is
only one way in which you can continue
surviving with black pieces you take I
take with a rook don't touch this
because of Queen to G6 sure that's
resignation on the spot that's dead so
you cannot touch that you're just giving
up uh the knife and now you're just
playing Knight E5 like nothing is
happening in the position and then I go
Rook F4 and uh the engine is saying that
black is slightly better I mean who in
the world knows exactly what's happening
in the position whoa whoa Bishop takes
E5 Bishop takes E5 I uh go Queen to E8
ah because I wanted you to take and I
would go Rook takes H6 crazy stuff
absolutely crazy stuff and as you were
mentioning if you take uh Queen to F7
Rook base H6
this one yeah I mean this one is yeah
that's so clear sorry Queen to F7 Rook
to G6 I'm going to pick up no that's
very good this is clear right so
wow crazy stuff he has to visualize all
of these variations from and by the way
Gregory stuff
it's done I mean you you're blitzing out
these moves this absolutely wild moves
I'm gonna stop and I'm gonna try to find
everything all the way until the end and
will he be able to do so I mean you say
it yes sir Only Time Will attack the
only time will yeah okay what what goes
through your mind you're at the
tournament game and your opponent's been
blitzing and he's or she have been
playing really crazy
double-edged moves like they know
everything don't you have this terrible
feeling that you've just walked into
massive prep how do you deal with that
yeah it's definitely very uncomfortable
when you know your opponent is in the
waters that they prepared and you don't
know how many even hours they spend on
that position and you know that like you
have to start making decisions because
there will be more difficult decisions
to come so you cannot spend all your
time here right so yeah sometimes it's
really you decide what you prefer like
Christian was saying if you move the
king to G8 F5 do you like those pawns so
close to your king or are you a little
bit worried and this is a bit
uncomfortable for me so I would be
looking for for those moves to capture
the pawn and then try to survive I know
that the move Knight E5 is kind of
difficult at the end of the but that's
not the end the 95 Bishop 5 Queen E8
that's the key move
because the Knight E5 is a bit logical
to block that Bishop you are willing to
kind of give up uh you know
any amount of Pawns you don't really
care about that you want to get out of
that position but the queen E8 move
that's that's a tough one that's a very
easy to move because we are like very
deep in the line like exactly and this
is the only move that holds that
position so if you don't see Queen E8
then you are like maybe even if I don't
like keeping those white pawns alive
yeah maybe it's my only way to to play
the crazy crazy stuff but uh it seems
like this Championship round has brought
out the best dare I say worst in the
players I mean there's another game
crazy game I mean like extended pawns if
we like players blitzing out their
preparation we have Rochelle over here
for that here Rochelle against Kelsey
Liu Rochelle has one hour 33 minutes so
she's also gaining time and look at
those black pawns those white pawns
right now this comes out of the nimzoo
Indian with F3 and this has become a
very topical line of play I remember
there was
um I think it was from uh Lavon aronian
game here at the sink fill cup
variation but check this out E5 Kelsey
said I am not going to play the precepts
of theory which involved 98 I'm gonna
sacrifice a piece Rochelle said okay
that's great I'm gonna take D4
A3
Bishop
B4 wow it takes takes Queen takes F6 and
now uh check this out I mean it almost
looks like fish are random right with
everything still on the first Rank and
C2 really kind of strong move black has
in their eyes yeah well a big threat
right the double attack you pick up the
Rook uh unguarded on A1 hit the queen so
this move Rook A2 which kind of is a
contradictory move right you don't want
you know you want to get your minor
pieces out so that you can Castle Rook
A2 side steps C2 prepares to meet any
check with Rook E2 uh Christian cleared
the cobwebs I have no idea what this
position is this Theory it's like
it's a it's a peace sacrifice but it
sure looks like great compensation fun
black is the one having fun it has been
played once once yes yes by uh volkov
versus gordievsky in 2012. gordievsky
was actually one of my initial students
at the University of Missouri no way yes
yes I I didn't know him in 2012
obviously well that explains crazy
tell me what this position is all about
it seems like black is doing just fine
no I was black is just much better in
English yes what has Rachelle done wrong
he takes C4
um well I'm not sure if Rochelle knows
that or once again she's maybe just
bluffing a little bit gambling a little
bit or maybe she has stronger engines
than I do because right now she has an
hour and 33 minutes on her clock so
definitely that gives the Insight that
perhaps she knows what she's doing
perhaps she's analyzed this at home okay
C4 seems to be the main move B4 is
another uh big option in the position
and yes after you play B B takes C4 the
computer is starting to say zero zero
zero so definitely uh it seems like the
engine this one at least is not strong
enough to analyze and assess correctly
this zero zero zero Queen to B5 King in
the center of the king in the center
right this is not developed go ahead
Queen D5 Queen D5 seems to be the main
one 96 right okay uh Knight to E2 if you
take on C4 then I just simply go Bishop
B7 and now things are pretty amazing
because I have too many uh things coming
your way Knight before Knight takes A5
is a big problem in the position coming
your way and you don't simply have
enough time to cover up your king for
example if you go Knight to E2 I take on
A5 or I go even Knight to E5 let's say
you take I take you take
yeah so let's see ah there's no way to
defend uh this is actually just over
right you can take on B7 but I have a
feeling Queen to H4 followed by Queen to
C4 it's like a pinball type of situation
right check I take this one I attack The
Rook I attack the Knight the Knight is
coming to D3 this one is looking really
really bad for white so nevertheless
Rochelle knows what she's doing so our
question is to kind of understand then
our task is to find out what she wants
perhaps she wants Knight to E2
not Queen to D5
in this position
but it seems like after Knight C6 Queen
to D5 still is the move and I think we
have a move yes B takes A4 is on the
board maybe we can see what Rochelle is
going to play next move that's uh that's
a big moment btc4 was played Rochelle
has been playing so fast she has to
continue playing fast because if she
doesn't like what in the world is she
doing
and the and the trick is funnily enough
not to play Bishop take C4 which you
want to do or a queen
to D5 but Knight E2 and like you were
saying she has three Bishop thanks C4
Queen H4 is game over yeah three extra
three extra minutes than what she
started with uh Rochelle is white has
been playing so quickly now it's not the
time to start thinking
come on but uh this has been the Alice
Lee show and the show is being taken
away from her as her game has really
been very quiet she and Iris when we
left it we left it just again at this
moment where I'm saying that Iris has an
easy position Bishop C5 oftentimes you
play a move like Bishop C5 you're
looking to play uh
Bishop B4 makes perfect sense developing
Bishop D2 Bishop E2 very very quiet game
going on here I want to check with Zoe
tang and Carissa yet because this was
the rookie eight moment right right and
uh whether you play Knight D2 you've got
to defend the pawn on C on e4 for me uh
Queen C2 was Zoe's Choice and then we've
just stopped
which is kind of intriguing
uh Carissa's looking at ideas like you
suggested Knight E4 maybe even his ideas
of Queen E7 and if you don't like any of
that stuff pressuring the part the
center with C7 C6 as well as Knight C5
still
I want to say it's a very sharp position
for the players and back over to you uh
Christian and uh you're you're with the
Juniors this fun game this fun game with
F6 early on and let's take a look at uh
how that one uh developed F6 Knight C3
A6 this is where we left it off and we
said that white has a plethora of
options at his disposal Bishop D3 Bishop
E2 Bishop E3 you can develop in a lot of
ways in this position and he chose to
develop and by the way Queen to A4 was
another move in the position as well or
queen to G3 to get out of Dodge of this
crazy
G5 right he decided to go Bishop E3 and
obviously hinting at the fact that he
wants to go to Long Castle right makes a
lot of sense it seems to be one of the
critical ways of dealing with this
position and we have E6 Castle F takes
E5 by the way Jose is still blitzing out
his moves you have to protect against
Checkmate 9 to F6 Queen to A4 and queen
to C7 and Jose still
um hasn't taught for a lot of time one
hour and 31 minutes on his clock one
hour and one minute for Andrew and as
you can see Josiah seems confident
Andrew is trying to understand the
position and I'm trying to understand
the position as well
how do you continue keeping the presence
of this Knight on E5 stable and probably
the answer is F4 okay you want to go F4
if you take on C6 by the way I really
think after uh B takes C6 maybe even
Bishop to D7 but btech C6 makes the most
sense it's looking good for black I go
Bishop D7 next Bishop D6 I have
everything very compact my Pawn
structure is very Compact and you cannot
take advantage of my wild initial play
right this is not something that you
want
so you want to go F4
question is how is black going to
respond to this if you go Bishop D6 just
the naturally Bishop D6 I have Knight B5
yeah that I like so that's a problem
right you have to get out of Dodge on
the a file right so it seems like the
continuation is either Knight to D7
which is at least to my estimation a bit
risky because of ideas of Knight B5
right or Rook to B8 Rook to ba Rook to
B8 get out of Dodge and try to go B5
maybe even support the move B5 and in
fact right now the only move for white
to preserve the advantage is Bishop A7
and then I get the bishop to D4 don't
ask me why yet
Rook to B8 and now G3
this is some alien chest to my eyes guys
I mean I understand why you put a bishop
on D4 you want sport this Knight and
then Bishop to D6 is going to come that
Knight on E5 is not going to be under
threat but these are difficult Concepts
totally to figure out over the
chessboard right so this one is not
going to be easy for Andrew Josiah still
within his preparation we'll see how
Andrew is going to react to this
difficult situation early on
enjoying 30 minutes Advantage right now
yeah well the element of surprise
definitely in his favor but crazy crazy
uh positions and uh well uh one of the
things that we kind of missed as we
started the show this so show started
with a bang but the players they're
fighting really really hard and what are
they fighting for let's just remind
everybody what the price is right varies
all about price funded in every single
tournament the U.S girls junior twenty
thousand dollars price found first place
six thousand dollars everyone gets a
price to replace 500 very nice and for
the junior players the junior is there
are fighting for 40 000 with the first
place taking home twelve thousand
dollars and again everyone gets a price
ten Place one thousand dollars and
there's a bonus price for our Junior
place as well we have Champions bonus
winners of the Juniors and junior girls
will be awarded a 10 thousand dollar
scholarship generously jointly funded by
the Dewayne Barber foundation and U.S
chess a big prize there with the
scholarships but also invitations to the
national championships the big dance big
dance and then this is a very nice prize
fund for the seniors 75 000 with the
first place winning twenty thousand
dollars and again last place three
thousand dollars very nice price fund
thank you again the St Louis chess club
and Scholastic centers for all you do I
just wanted to jump in
for the senior section for a moment uh
Malik said he's coming in uh to this uh
round
cruising he doesn't want to spoil a
fantastic result so far he mentioned
that he likes to play the black site or
the morocci
the irony is he's on the white side and
uh this all-important round against
Patrick Wolfe and the players have
gotten to a very standard I want to say
a kind of Hedgehog position last move by
black A7 A6 kind of Intimates that yeah
I would like to play B5 try to knock
this Pawn on C4 out of the way so that
in the future I could play D5 I'm going
to say White's enjoying a slight space
Advantage at the moment but really my
experience positions very balanced yeah
and let's just remind our viewers what
ifs uh because he's doing so well in the
tournament Kate right if melee catching
wins he wins the tournament he cleanses
the title and if medication draws and a
shovel of doesn't win then catching
still wins the tournament so Grand
Master married catching really great
looking in this round uh wonderful
performance thus far a7a A6 again
normally what white is trying to do is
play Rook to D1 put as much pressure on
the pawn on A3 sometimes the bishop pops
out to A3 and tries to drive the Knight
back you know I really like this
position for a while I like to play
maruti because exactly white has so many
targets and you can just be slowly
moving around and I think it's very
risk-free well you'll be surprised
people like um oh uh The Grandmaster
from Sweden all of Anderson has more
than once you know suckered his about
opponent into trying to kill him and
turn the tables again I think Dynamic
equality I understand what you mean
about
playing uh risk free I mean I like white
in this place also I'm I'm a big fan of
white spawn structure White's control I
see this pressure on the D file I feel
like I exchanged the right pieces right
I don't have the bad light Square Bishop
that's behind the pawn wall I have that
beautiful Bishop on B2 ready to get
opened on the long diagonal and create
Havoc I have to say I like what Malik
has been doing and I think he's in poor
position to maybe get another Victory by
the way if he wins this one it's over
well then it's over yeah so we got that
yeah we we know that and by the way take
a look at his time 125 minutes for him
one hour and four minutes for Patrick so
perhaps
because not all together happy points to
the fact that Malik is comfortable with
this position and maybe even knows the
theoretical underpinnings of this
position of how it goes all right we'll
definitely keep an eye on uh this one
how about yourself uh uh Christian what
have you been studying I've been looking
at the Juniors I've been looking at this
game of abhimani because this is crucial
right if he needs a victory in this one
he's facing the lowest rated opponent in
the field and he needs to win
and this kind of surprised me early on
he played this move Bishop to C4 let's
remind everybody what Arthur does after
Bishop to B5 he does this Knight G E7
followed by G6
he played it twice already in this
tournament and in both of those games he
was lost by move 15. he did not know the
theory so uh surprisingly abhimani
decides not to challenge him in that
variation again he says okay you messed
it up a couple of times I mean you're
probably not going to mess it up the
third time so I'm gonna switch it up
early in the opening he plays Bishop to
C4 he decides to go for the Joker piano
and we get this position A4 Knight A5
and C5 still looking for some sort of a
chiguring type of structure with Knight
A5 C5 early on
A6 Knight to A3 Bishop to G4 Bishop to
D2 I like this move Bishop to D2
getting the bishop out but at the same
time leaving the E3 Square
um open for the night and this is what
he's looking to get this is what he got
Knight to E3 Bishop to H5 and Knight to
D5 this is what we have on the board
right now definitely white is enjoying a
slight advantage and I think this is
what perhaps uh with this Joker piano he
was looking to achieve a long game in
which I have pressure as white abimanu
is looking to slowly but surely outplay
his opponent and I have to say he's off
to a good start
nice uh picking up on the theme of this
rui Lopez variation in the game between
Jason and Liang and Arthur go again
we're seeing this rui Lopez the bishop
on E3 kind of a little echo of what
Christian was just describing last move
by Black Knight to B5 these Bishops
lurking menacingly along these diagonals
I do like Jason's move coming up right
sorry here I like this move D for D5 a
lot
basically take away the trumps that your
opponent has in this case the Bishops
look really good offer the trait of
Bishops which occurred by the way Bishop
takes E3 Rook takes E3 the bishop on B7
suddenly is not that attractive and on a
good day I get to play the moves Rook C3
and Rook C1 and pressure the backward
Pawn on C7 so our tournament leader at
the moment Arthur I don't think he
actually came out of this opening in a
position that he's can I go C6 that's I
guess that's a question immediately
trying to break the center open up that
light Square Bishop that's the way to go
forward and I I take it right if you
take with the queen
my intention for what it's worth was to
try this move Rook to C3 uh hoping to
use the C file and if you take with the
bishop well I'm thinking Knight D4
not necessarily that I'm looking to go
there just trying to say my Pawn
structure is a little bit better if I go
Rook C8 Rook ac8 Rook a C8
I'd love to open up the the
a file for a moment
works
I am worried about the discovered
attacks I guess
I guess I'd have to take
yeah I will take with the rug yeah it's
not
I'm not getting
the nice the big Edge the nice Edge that
I want uh yet I mean if I can get my
positional grip on the position
something in it for white but back over
to you uh Christian uh I think games
and this question came along yesterday I
I think you asked him kashka Brandon
what will your strategy be are you going
to go all in with the black pieces in
the next game and he said I'm not going
to reveal that and you will see tomorrow
and this is exactly what he's doing he's
I in my estimation at least
sort of going all in because he chose
the king's India right King's Indian
Bishop to it when we have this variation
with E5 Bishop to G4 A4 one of the main
lines and H5 whoa
trying to gain space on the king side
King to H7 and queen to C2 this is what
we have right now obviously Justin has
been surprised by his times manager uh
Brandon Jacobson with one hour and 20
minutes seems to hint at the fact that
he still knows sort of what the idea is
in the position uh are and the question
we're out of theory at this point the
question is how are you going to
continue obviously as black you want to
play on the king side you've already
established that you played H5 King H7
most likely at some point this Knight is
going to drop back to G8 and you're
going to open up uh the way for a DF
Pawn to come along the way or H4
followed by Knight H5 and then F5 right
this is another way to continue your
attack sure white on the other hand
obviously is going to try to push and
gain some more space on the queen side
how do you make B4 happen is the
question do you go Rook a B1 do you
start with B3 first because once you go
Rook a B1 Queen to E7 has been played as
we we were discussing this and the
question is do you start with B3
following up with Rook to A1 then B4
this seems to be the best way in which
you can continue but again it's all
about H4 or Knight to G8 followed by F5
this is a very double edged position and
I think this is exactly what Brandon is
looking for he's going to take some
risks sure maybe he's going to have a
worse position I think we were at this
conference and Gary Gary Kasparov at
some point said that whenever he's
looking at the king's uh Indian defense
and analyzing it with the new engines he
gets depressed and he hates that because
the engine is always going to give white
a tremendous Advantage back in his day
you know these positions we didn't
really know how to assess it was wild
stuff with the engine sure you're
probably going to be able to find a way
to an advantage but Justin doesn't have
an engine with him right now Jacobson
definitely knows exactly the plans and
how to continue his attack on the queen
side this is a Gamble and we'll see
whether it pays off but this is once
again a good start for Brandon as well
if I can keep you on this position for
just a moment and I if I'm ingested
shoes I desperately want to play B4 and
C5 and get in my queen side attack
before you get to play your knight G8
and F5 and F4 or your H4 Knight H5 yeah
so Rook to B1 to my mind
accelerated move and I take it you take
that pawn yes I'm uh I'm a pawn Grabber
give me the pawn
okay maybe I shouldn't give it
he gives me a fun and now he's crying
I tricked you you tricked me out I did I
did I did yeah
um okay I forgot to mention one plan
very important for black yes which I
think is Bishop to H6
ah now that he got this King to H7
perhaps Bishop H6 is a dual purpose move
exactly gain some space maybe trade off
the dark Square so Bishop only after
okay
B4 a takes eight takes get the king to
G7 how do you continue I want to play C5
can you play C5 I don't know if I can or
can't but it won't be what is on the
board by the way Rook a B1 is on it's on
the board yeah so with the queen on E7
probably and that's why he played Queen
97 just to slow down C5 I will take so
you still have to labor a little bit in
the position to get that C5 going you
don't have Knight B3 to support it
because you lose the B4 right so it's a
bit awkward it's not that clear how
you're going to arrange your pieces to
get C5 going in the position uh by the
way we have on the board this page six
is on the board yeah yes so Brandon
definitely knows he knows he knows what
he's doing for sure yes by the way
yes let's see what Bishop takes H6 King
takes H6 the players are both moving
like this is
somehow part of their preparation I
think it's part of Brandon's preparation
um otherwise he wouldn't speed through
these moves and B4
not a part of
um Justin's no but once you played Rook
a B1 there's only one friend right yes
exactly
by the way how are our Andrews our
Arthurs doing by the way I mean we have
a cool game in the care gazarian Balaji
dagupati and Andrew Hong Josiah siren
because we have the Rook B8 on the board
nothing has happened yes we've already
seen this position this is crazy I I
love the move Bishop D4 a bishop A7 by
the way uh Bishop A7 you tickle The Rook
you would think that B5 would be a good
move but it should be eight is like
you're in trouble after that I'm so
unhappy Rook back to AAA you I think in
my mind's eye moving the bishop to the
D4 square with the tempo that makes a
lot of sense to me you know I kind of
and then we were like was it gg3 G3 this
is not easy stuff because you do kind of
have to follow it up with G3 right
otherwise B5 uh weighs itself out I
don't think you can take on C6 because
of Queen takes F4 yes it's a very tricky
position to play over the board I have
to say the the move G3 just to stop this
type of uh Intermezzo it's very weird
right yeah it's a weird move but G3 okay
maybe one day the bishop will jump out
whether I have to trade on C6 or not
crazy crazy stuff and uh you were
mentioning Kate yourself some other
amazing games
C4 allowing the king to be checked yeah
that E5 move uh when we left it we were
kind of leaving it around here there was
a trade of the night then that important
move F6 visual catch chased
can't interpose the Queen Bishop B4 will
be hurtful yeah you do not really the
move you would like to know of the
castle and then takes F3 okay so here I
mean White's trying to find some safety
first king but uh Christian was saying
you know like this Pawn is pretty
dangerous Bishop A3 uh moving to protect
and I'm I'm guessing uh King King F2 is
on Kirk's your initial feelings I think
it's very dangerous for white this Pawn
on C3 I would just go with it
immediately okay uh should I be playing
to you know like my King's all messed up
we would that's already been established
no argument there but maybe King is also
a little bit messed up but you can't
Castle
um because I uh I've covered G8
uh very cleverly right so once I go
Bishop D7
I think I'm gonna allowing you today yes
I don't know if you're trustworthy or
not if I take the pawn
you're going to play with CA well I
thought if I can just Castle in and play
c2o I mean it's not mine right I can
give it up this is the wonderful part
about being a chess commentator when we
make a mistake we get to say oh well the
variation didn't work let's try
something else right when they make a
mistake you know like they're crying for
the rest of the evening you know it's
very committed On the Border whereas
here we can just take it back I mean
here I'm kind of liking white this is
this is we're in Crazy territory how is
Alice Lee doing not great not great not
great she's actually much worse right
now no way and in some sort of a
simplified position so I wouldn't say
that irises moves are difficult to get
to that better position
um this is what we have right now okay
Knight to D4 was the last move and the
question is what do you do against Queen
G5 I can start with Queen G5 I can take
and then go Queen to G5 okay this is a
very typical idea you go Castle I go
Bishop to H3 and then you lose an
exchange you go G3 I pick up the Rook on
F1 very very typical pattern so how do
you do it I mean I guess you can take on
C6 but sure that weakens my Pawn
structure but also opening up the D5
will help me once I land The Rook on d8
once I landed look on B8 I have a lot of
pressure in once again the question is
how do you defend G2
do you go King F1 and leave the king and
the rook's not connected to each other
that's going to be very dangerous right
right maybe G4 by the way G4 is the move
proposed by the engine uh to my eyes
nobody plays Jesus
it's a bit crazy right I mean I think I
I think you kind of say okay I messed
things up a little bit I go King F1 and
I hope I can play H4 H5
I'm coming yeah I agree I'm not happy
with Alice I'm coming really really fast
and then I'm going to go Bishop to E6
Queen comes to E5 right no I have Queen
C3 though you go Queen C3 okay but now
Bishop to G4 taking advantage of the
fact that you don't have protection on
the back rack on D1 I mean this in fact
is already losing for why wow so Alice
Lee in a bit of trouble early on in this
one still Iris needs to find the precise
move she's not losing any material
immediately the queen G5 is the key it's
simple and it's very effective right and
it begs to be played sure you want to
play Queen G5 you know everybody knows
this pattern everybody learns this queen
G5 and if you Castle Bishop H3 pattern
early on in their career right so
um interesting one definitely and uh
if she loses that could open up the
opportunity for Zoe Tang as you can see
only one point behind and maybe get
closer maybe even equalizer score well I
always would move to the you know third
place potentially with with her win so
also very important came for her to try
to play for medals uh by the way I don't
think I I'm not a fan of Zoe's opening
play uh thus far when we left it she
um Carissa played this move Rook E8 it's
a little bit and it's not a little bit
annoying it's very very annoying the
bishop on E3 is unprotected there's uh
tactics that you had shown with Knight
takes E4 and F5 and after Queen C2
Knight to B6 uh Carissa is menacing
Knight takes D5 again taking advantage
of the fact that this bishop on E3 is
unprotected I'm not a fan of this move
Bishop F2 I'm looking at this position
and I'm saying yes give fight two moves
Castle short and you know brings her
Rooks to the center with E5 it's it's
Splat it's game over but what do you do
after you move like Knight age five
okay and now it's sort of like obvious
suddenly uh I don't want to allow right
night to F4 I don't want to play g3 at
least H3 really weaker for the bishop on
CA right but if you play Queen D2 which
looks like a very standard way of uh
meeting such an attack move like Bishop
H6
and you're like gosh darn it will you
will you leave me alone will you stop
interfering attacking those pawns right
without my over push and again if you
continue with G3 uh it it has that feel
of whites being the one on the back foot
a little bit you know I was even looking
if I can be more brutal can I just do
Knight takes E4 uh app now right now oh
my sorry I wasn't even in that direction
so um
D5 is hanging the Knight then can
capture on F4 that is a very good
question first of all you have Queen E7
but that's Pawn number two right and I'm
still gummied up with my my pieces Zoe
could be in serious trouble here
Christian Knight takes E4 after uh
Bishop F2
what does the computer say it no no
trouble whatsoever exactly
uh Christian
no no sorry what
you guys were asking me something you're
right yes yes yes I was letting you guys
figure it out by yourself
very much
I'm not going to give you any Helping
Hands yes correct answer is yes sir
you're right just go ahead practice
Katarina you're right thank you
Christian
I know that one
the inmates are taking over just a
second what's going on
we have Knight H5 on the board we do
have night before was very very strong
Knight E4 was very strong 94 was in fact
very very brutal and the variation that
you guys analyzed with Queen to E7
Bishop to F5 followed by Queen 37 right
and try to defend that I will take only
for play F5 if you go Bishop D3 or
Bishop to F3 okay that's going to be an
extra Pawn right for me and fi that's a
beautiful pleasure beautiful position
absolutely no problems you're not
risking anything anymore you're going to
be a pawn up and probably the
compensation as well so big missed
opportunity I have to say foreign
oh as you are mentioning Yasser as well
Knight H5 definitely comes also its own
perks in the position as well it's not
as aggressive and as precise as an I
take C4 but it's also still a difficult
position for uh for Zoe we see so we saw
a very nice camera view there of Zoe and
she's stoic at the board I mean uh the
eyes are darting around but yeah I I
like to see a little bit more worry when
I play a move like Knight H5 he's he
looks pretty calm wow so we have the two
liters Alice Lee and so we think Under
Pressure yeah Under Pressure so please
sir Christian Andrew did go into that
variation with Bishop A7 Bishop D4
kudos to him seriously and now the
question is and he has 38 minutes left
on his clock against an hour and 33
minutes will he take the draw this is a
big big moment right now will he take
the draw with display seven he can't
afford to draw he cannot afford a draw
exactly
yeah but he has an hour Less on his
clock true and he's nowhere close at
least in his mind he's not sure whether
Josiah has finished his arrest I mean
you can play the best moves maybe G3 and
perhaps Josiah still has another 5-10
moves and once again just to remind
everybody uh Josiah is sitting there on
Ninth position with two points you think
if you're Andrew you can jump on the
trampoline score a victory get five and
say somebody take care of Arthur for me
you know and that would be nice but I've
I find myself drawn to the move G2 G3
for Andrew how about yourself it's just
because I always ask my pieces where
would they like to go I play a move like
G3 the bishop says yeah I'm perfectly
happy but yeah it's it's really tough
I'm telling you it's really tough
because Bishop takes Ace what do you
okay you play G3 what do you play after
Bishop D6 the most natural move in the
position
Bishop to D6 I take a pawn yes you have
to and now I go Rook A8 Bishop takes A6
Rook A8 I was hoping Knight B5
queen queen d8
Queen Diego yes and now the best move is
Knight A7
you were saying I'm choking this setting
me up the strap because Knight A7 was
not in my you cite a vision like what
I'm seeing these moves nice I'm starting
to choke right now okay okay
somebody want uh one Christian we want
Fair analysis Knight A7 and by the way
this is zero zero by The Andrews finally
we got to this position and yeah this is
zero zero zero but yeah I'm so impressed
like all those Juniors they play
computer when they are prepared they
play them even if they are not prepared
like we saw abhimanyu and make sure just
playing best lines yeah like even here
Andrew so far playing best lines I mean
I would never think about that move but
I wouldn't be surprised if actually
Andrew found it that is just an amazing
amazing move Well he kind of has to find
it but he has to find it from all the
way from here right he makes this
decision to play G3 because after Bishop
D6 if you don't go into this line black
has solved all his problems right right
if you go back let's say Knight F3 I
don't have any problems no I don't no
I'm not I go Castle now your Bishop on
D4 is actually misplaced because I'm
threatening to take it it's not a good
position for you right no I'm not happy
with Knight F3 and I'm starting to look
at that Queen maybe I will trap it at
some point 100 sure I'm I'm only two
moves away from crabbing I'm not exactly
what the queen is doing there right now
right exactly so this is not an easy
decision for Andrew
let us just check in on Arthur the Jason
Liang Arthur Geo game by the way they
did
followed
our our analysis their takes on C6 has
just been played yeah Blake really wants
to free up that bishop and attack the
center I'm going to check in on Kirk and
uh Balaji because that was yeah this was
F3 Bishop A3 King over B5 B5 not uh I
was thinking that as desirable as C3 is
you know Queen yeah it brings up a lot
of light squares I agree yeah and so I
like the move b7b5 Queen C2 on the board
and menacing a check yeah I can see
those double attacks now I guess it's
time to get the king out of the center
and I think that this position is just a
mess I hate my Rook on H1 so I find
myself drawn to the idea of H4 and H5
but
um yeah the positions just completely
completely absurd
I have no idea what's going on here
um so what about the Justin Wang and
Brandon Jacobson we saw the king Take H6
moved there trading the dark Square
Bishops really different approach takes
takes wow and B4 not King G7 which was
made before but C5 so black is Switching
gears and going to the queen side now
now unfortunately for me the desirable
takes on C5 Knight takes C5 and I I
can't grab at the pawn on B7 I think the
Knight on C5 is good enough
I don't know what do you think about
this position I'm gonna I I I'm fighting
for the queen side as white when I'm
playing against the king's Indian I
don't and let me emphasize this I don't
want to close the great side I feel like
anytime I play B5 night before closing
the queen side I'm doing my favor my
opponent a big favor you're just gonna
wait for black to roll on the king size
of course and I don't want to wait for
that to happen so I'm thinking
and I'm thinking takes on C5 those for
me those are my two choices the office
on and uh wow check this out Justin is
not what are you saying he's reaching
what is he reaching he's reaching I
don't know uh I think he's going for the
ampa song right oh man we lost her we
lost it
the moment he was reaching so uh I just
want to say to the players and
especially the youth Young players in
our audience
when you do this you're giving me
confidence because it's sort of like
you're being hesitant you're you're
you're you're you're you're you're
you're giving me a tell you're telling
me that you're not for sure so I really
I really like it when you do this when
you grab a piece with authority you make
the move and you press your clock like
you know what you're doing when you're
like
[Laughter]
a little California cool with a little
uh nervousness you know uh going on
there with the with the shape uh APPA
song or B Tech C5 uh what do you think
Kate if you were in uh Justin's shoes
are you capturing on C5 or are you
capturing on C6 so I am not 100 sure
what I would do but the first
that pawn on C5 yeah actually both are
taking born on C5 but this is what I
meant right I'm very happy on creating
that weakness on B7 correct we're
talking about the Knight on C5 so can I
do Knight B3 exactly Target that night
exactly and then let's say I go B7 B6 so
if you do trade you're doing me a favor
of potentially
um getting rid of my weakness right
right but I did force you to move the
pawn to B6 but it's no longer defended
by the Knight exactly exactly
so yeah I'm not sure maybe Rook A1 now
try to go to that file well you can do
again if you're in white shoes and you
go okay great good for you you got rid
of your Pawn weakness but good for me I
got the queen side opened way before
you've played you're not even close to
F5 F 4G so I I'm more or less I feel
like I'm dictating not necessarily that
I'm winning or I have some huge
advantage or anything of that nature
just the idea that you haven't
even you you your attack on the king
side hasn't even matured at all it's not
even visible whereas maybe you know I've
got something going on the the queen
side anyway for Justin uh for Brandon
Jacobson by the way Brandon uh he uh
very much uh like Andrew needs a win
needs a win as uh we're coming up to uh
break territory it's our time to check
into our good friends over at cute
Boutique and we've got to figure out
what what we're being offered as a
special well here it is everybody it's
the St Louis chess club in Scholastic
Center chess a travel bag tote you roll
up board and chess pieces in style with
the official St Louis chess logo travel
bag the zipper pouch holds a chest an
entire set of pieces comfortably while
your board fits underneath gold screen
printed ink on durable vinyl don't
forget the chess pieces the vinyl
roll-up board as well all your chest
needs are available in cupertik St
louis.com and we're going to see
everybody on the inside of the Ring
right
foreign
[Music]
the Missouri Bicentennial commission
along with Governor Mike Parson approved
the building of a life-size chess board
to celebrate the 200th anniversary of
the state of Missouri Dr Jeannie
sinkfield a lifelong patron of scouting
in Great Rivers Council board member
proposed that the project be built as an
Eagle Scout project Jeannie invited 16
year old Andrew Dowden of troop 6
Jefferson City to take on this
incredibly important project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone and started playing chess and I
took the chess merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite
I wasn't very familiar with the
technology needed to engrave on there so
I needed some assistance with that and
learning how to do it and after all that
I'm pretty sure I know how to do it now
so to engrave those Edge pieces I went
down to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project Jeannie was
there I had to give a little speech that
I didn't really know I had to do but
that kind of of has taught me a little
bit about speaking too so I think that
has helped me too this project it's made
me real proud that everyone is enjoying
it like every time I go down there
somebody's playing
um and then they're taking care of it
which really makes me proud because me
thinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time I like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate it
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today hello I'm women's grunt
Master William takorjanova I will be
doing social media for the US Juniors
and seniors chess championships follow
us in our social media and get more
exciting behind the scenes action
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
foreign
Hall of Fame located in the heart of St
Louis's historic Central West End want
to know why chess's intrigued people
around the world for nearly 1500 years
stop by and learn about the impact of
Chess from our three floors showcasing
the art culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions and our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit worldchess
hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
Tucker jonoa I'm doing social media for
the U.S Juniors and seniors
championships here in San Luis follow us
for more exciting behind the scenes
content
foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to our live coverage of
the national championships as we have
one result of the seniors and a very
important one at that Cape right we have
catching drawing with Patrick Wolfe
cementing his lead yeah and if shabalov
doesn't win right then we have a
champion
exactly let's just jump right into that
game and see why because both yourself
and Christian felt very comfortable uh
with white in the position and they've
reached this position and after the move
Queen C5
just stopping for the moment this move
Bishop A3 and saying okay go ahead what
are you going to do well Malik said I
don't like your I don't like your queen
on the C5 Square go back Patrick Wolf
did go back and then he went back and
again I'm looking at Bishop A3 on my uh
agenda
and the players simply repeated and for
Malik said I mean it's a tournament of
his dreams right and actually the draw
is really good because even if he
doesn't win that tournament right away
he has really won last round to focus on
and so all the I all uh I uh our eyes
turned to this one remaining game that
is to say the game between Dimitri
gurvich and Alexander shambalov because
now it's incumbent upon shabalov to win
this game so that there's a lot of
meaningful round to play for tomorrow
now let's take a look at what happened
in this game with Dimitri gurvich Knight
E5 looks like a a pleasant move to be
sure I mean you're you're that Knight on
d7s in a pin Knight C6 on White's agenda
you're almost forced I I want to say you
are forced to take take F2 F4 castles
says okay at last I've got a threat I've
got a threat of playing Knight C5
forking Queen and Bishop by the way on a
good day this bishop on B7 is just
waiting an answer I mean if I can shovel
if I'm happy to have this position to
play for for win right to complicate
kind of stuff absolutely anything kind
of equal or boring this is a position I
think he will he's happy about no
question about it uh shabalov as we say
he's a one of those players who just
loves the chaos the problem is as I see
it that is there enough Chaos on the
board that he could deal say a castle so
I kind of sidestep any ideas of Queen
check of course I understand I am
inviting you to play Knight C5 Queen C2
give me the pawn on B7 if we get a
bishops of opposite color game are you
do you have enough to win you know what
I'm saying this is where the the this is
where I'm questioning uh yes you could
play Bishop A6 yes I'm thinking I'll
play Queen to D1 the night I'm not sure
I'm not sure if I want to be trading
that night for the bishop a castle is
lost castles is lost thank you you
touched the king you Castle you resign
scores in the next three moves wow what
am I what have I missed I take on C4
first
take on C4 first yes
you think with anything and now I go
Queen H4 Queen G3 and I make you on the
board that is very pretty hello
mate on H2 defense mate on G2 or H2 H2
very typical pattern oh my gosh easy to
miss and if I play Bishop to eat you
have to do bishopy too then you still
got Queen H4 and I'm just a pawn up and
I mean position is devastating you have
to take and then go Queen C2 I'm not
happy you're not happy no I'm not you're
absolutely
I would probably we have but I'm
struggling no no I I I I no me gusta
so castles that's a nice move Queen H4
Queen G3 didn't see it and if you would
want to play something like H3 to First
Kick That Knight away I can't that'll be
super big blunder as well a queen H4
immediately flying there oops game over
that one I could definitely see uh boy
uh Bishop E2 but some troubles here for
Demetrius he's working it out vote let's
go to Christian with guest in studio
Malik I'm not going to ask you too much
about the game because it doesn't have a
lot of history but what was the strategy
going into today's round given that
you're one point ahead one point and a
half ahead of shabalov well I mean I
wanted to keep tension but I mean hey I
kind of missed could be six movie my
preparation it's actually very sneaky I
didn't realize screaming six we spoke
briefly it's uh that's led me to play D4
I thought he's playing D5
yes and um
I didn't see that kind of was coming so
I was trying to get position like this
with slightly Edge and then I realized I
had to play something like D3 because I
didn't want to play like nasty three
because Knight E5 yeah and I thought
through the one is actually smart uh
waiting move it was a very good move
yeah yeah but then apparently he also
analyze this as well but then he'd been
debating As I understood like between
like rookie 8 and queen C6 so
but I mean okay if we play squishy6 that
I mean this General trade is supposed to
be just uh equal and and honestly the
whole time I I couldn't understand how
to behave how to play right right
exactly difficult yeah so
and I didn't want to take a risk here
because I don't think so I have anything
like particular
um
and a drug guarantees you the tie breaks
at least yeah but I don't I hope it's
not going to happen
at least you have something in your
pockets well actually tomorrow is going
to be much more easier for me to uh to
sort of psychologically play today I
couldn't sleep really I mean I slept
like maybe three hours top I mean I just
didn't know like okay what to do what to
do what to do I play like open Sicily
and do I play against neither like
kailano there do I play like a D4
against his like King Syrian defense or
a grundfell I like I didn't know like
what to do and that situation when you
sort of in between yeah like are you
hanging in there I I just said yes and
you know what it's I remember like when
I was a kid
um uh petrogen uh shared his story uh
when he played Curacao and when he was I
think he was half pointing at right yes
I should remember better than me history
and
um he said this he was doing the same
stories he said so he couldn't control
him so it was a very difficult situation
and then he made just a draw and said so
you know what whatever if it's going to
happen it's going to happen yeah that's
it so I kind of start to like thinking
think and think I said you know what
whatever let's let's do this let's let's
take a draw and then let's put myself
you know on the fate of the history so
we'll see we'll see what's going to
happen there's obviously a lot riding on
this couple of uh games tell us a bit
about your support system I'm sure you
need that whenever you have this type of
difficult nights not sleeping what is
your support system who is your support
system maybe it's the best um
my kids voice
yeah usually like before I go to bed I'm
calling home I'm talking to my kids and
that kind of uh come calm myself down
and um yeah and then I'm trying to also
have a couple of friends who is like
true friends to me and they always try
to be really nice to me and whenever I
feel a kind of you know difficult
moments I'm I'm kind of calling them or
texting them or something like that and
um yeah I mean I I can't say I didn't
sleep like at all I slept obviously but
what I'm saying is you know whenever you
sleep and then whenever you see
something and then you like waking up
against sleep waking up you know
something like that but I mean it was
okay it's okay
I just woke up uh around like what 6
37ish
so that's fine yeah I mean it's still a
great position to be in and as a
competitor I'm sure you dream about
these type of moments in every single
game every single tournament you're
playing so yeah no complaints you know
like I also to my students like imagine
this if someone would propose you to
have this situations before the event
would you take it I mean obviously I
would take it obviously yeah yeah I
would take it but I I realize Shabba is
going to win because I think his FL was
really terrible uh by goreevich but
that's a fine his his looking good right
now yes it's still not very far from
over or anything but anyway I thought it
was again whatever but we'll see we'll
see I like to play Shabba so it's going
to be a very interesting matchup
tomorrow yeah I like this kind of
intensity
guys any questions for Malik as he goes
into that final battle Yeah it's your
preparation in now
I love it I I I love uh just the story
he was saying there because when you
hear him speak about you know waking up
in the morning and the first thing
that's on his mind is should I play an
open Sicilian should I do it like this
it's always very difficult Direction
about Chess that's what it's about that
passion it's it's in your blood right
yep exactly and good luck good luck
absolutely uh just turning our attention
to the game of Alice Lee for a second I
do expect a kind of a repetition going
on here uh with Iris and we the players
reach this position King D2 and and from
Alice's perspective if she could just
play the move Rook here and King E3
she's golden I mean the position is
excellent for white but iris is not
gonna allow that right
and
the King had to come back King dropped
back to D2 The Rook back drop back King
E3 and this is the repetition that we
anticipate and that will be a draw Alice
is just looking at her score sheet now
by the way with this draw and a one
point lead only if Zoe can beat Carissa
uh
would deny Alice the the title already
right but it's good to remind viewers
that Alice is really happy to make a
draw in this game right uh actually
irismo was the player in this game who
had some chances to maybe be pushing a
little bit around yeah I think the uh
guitarist Gambit kind of uh caught Alice
unprepared she didn't handle it very
well and look she's looking at the score
sheet to just make sure she is claiming
she's gonna write to move down
repetition correctly claim the
repetition stop the clock show The
Arbiter that with this move I claim a
three-fold repetition in E3 and uh
yeah
and that's the right way
the Arbiter agrees uh with the claim
when you
yeah and the youngest players are having
a draw in their game
good well that again just as before as
in the senior section that means that
all eyes are turning to the Zoe tank
Carissa Yip game because once again if
Zoe is not able to win uh then Alice is
uh the girls champion and a ten thousand
dollar scholarship not so fast not so
fast because Zoe with a draw she will
still be within Striking Distance a
point she's one point behind excuse
right so there's a tie-break situation
of the tie break but I have to say I
mean Carissa is looking good right now
exactly in this game against Zoe Zoe is
under tremendous pressure so maybe
Carissa you know has the opportunity to
play spoilers in this one and allow
Alice to celebrate with one round to go
Knight H5 by the way we when we left it
I said
I didn't like playing the move G2 G3 but
you know what are you going to do the
pawn on F4 stands out like a sore thumb
you can't simply allow your opponent to
capture it the problem with G3 is it
just means the pawn on H3 is hanging and
you're not going to be castling short
anytime soon in fact because you're not
going to be castling short anytime soon
uh Carissa prepares to open up the queen
trying to kind of move the pieces around
and put even more pressure on that pawn
on e4 and in the center C6 takes on C6
Bishop takes C6 Bishop F3 we've caught
up with the players I was about to say
it wasn't commentators curse because I
just didn't have the chance to get it in
but I want to play the move D5 as uh
black and you know open up the position
when the Rooks are not connected and the
king is sitting in the way and I'm
assuming like that I kind of closed my
eyes and just hope that the tactics all
work for me and with this move uh
Carissa did not do this by the way I
want to emphasize she did play the move
Rook C8 we've caught up with the players
and your take on I mean why would we
really happy to get quickly King G2 and
rook he1 and that would be the dream
it's doing perfectly yeah that would be
the dream King G2 rookie one yeah but
this Rook on C8 is kind of pinning the
Knight on C3 right
is there
wait is that a problem I was about to
say you know you have to count right
right Knight takes Knight takes Bishops
eggs Bishop takes so far nothing no no
good
good that I didn't blunder upon and but
you were you were about to say The Rook
there could be some issues this kind of
thing right uh still not I still have to
count
right right but uh I think this is what
Carissa has on her agenda but I want to
throw uh the ball in your direction uh
Christian what do you have
looking at this game guys Kirk garzarian
versus Balaji dagupati Balaji has it in
the back if he finds the next move it's
a minus four advantage what
if he finds this very unnatural move
Queen to A4 wow this is not obvious I
thought wow why why is it so strong
because you cannot stop the C Pawn
there's no more stopping the C block the
only way try to do something is to go
here but now I go Bishop B2 now you're
losing this one now I get the other Pawn
to A3
ouch cementing the bishop B2 there's no
way for you to uh defend the A2 Pawn
you're going to have to sacrifice The
Exchange and that's not going to save
you because I'm still going to continue
with A3 if you stay on the second rank
for example something like this then I
go Rook to B8 Rook to B to absolutely
nothing saving you at this point this is
all she wrote and Balaji could be
continuing with another crucial Victory
I think his hat-trick he would complete
a hat-trick if he wins this one and uh
huge important moment right now will he
find Queen to A4 and I have by the way
Queen A4 I think is on the board
it's on the board he found it wow and
Kirk is holding his head in his hand
like in this belief right now what am I
just witnessed this is the demolition
of white of kyrgyzarian in this game 20
moves and he can't sign this course
Balaji only four minutes to find this
move and decide on this so he's planning
the position completely and Balaji is on
fire right now right
wow
uh nice nice move for those of you of
you who are joining us late we had this
uh crazy discussion of the game that was
going on between Rochelle Wu and Kelsey
it was the triple pons it's a peace
sacrifice and it's crazy enough actually
even topical so when we left it we left
it in this position after Rook a two
takes we didn't look at the move F4 of
course we were looking mainly at moves
like Queen to D5 as well as Knight to E2
the move F4 feels too slow though we
have all of his underdeveloped and you
push another Pawn right the highly
desirable move Bishop takes C4 walks
into a nasty double attack Queen H4
check followed by Queen take C4 how many
of us have followed for this
many times right once it's not enough as
James
okay the move F2 F4 really Taking
Liberties but uh from Rochelle's point
of view if she could play Bishop take C4
Knight F3 she would be a happy camper
Bishop A6 Knight F3 Rook d8 Bishop E3
Knight C6 we've caught up with the
players Rochelle
piece up asking your opponent the
question
Kelsey she wants to play Just D5 D4 D3
D2 I mean the road is ready for the pawn
there and that was what Rook d8 was all
about so here we go right isn't it is it
time D5
because we played Knight C6 well I'm
gonna stop you from playing I mean I
don't want to play Bishop E2 castles and
see D5 D4 land on the board so I guess
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to stop you
Queen You're Gonna Go Rook B8 right
right I'm gonna play Bishop I'm assuming
you're gonna play Rook B1 Shaq yes and
I'm gonna defend
close my eyes
ugliest positions
look it's not it's not always about
Style Style points doesn't always win
the games uh but uh that's just a crazy
game we'll keep an eye on this as we
have guests in studio Christian Alice uh
difficult game for you but you did uh
what an experienced player would do and
you managed to pull the brakes with the
white pieces tell us the story of this
game yeah I mean so I went into the game
thinking like a balloon would be nice
um but like I was okay with the draw uh
it's just like a loss is more like
detrimental than a Winner's positive so
I think
um I mean I'm okay with the result I
mean I would have hoped for like
something better but after like she
surprised me in the opening
um I think I played a bit passively and
I didn't really have any chances at what
point did you start thinking okay it's
time it's time to pull the brakes I'm in
the worst position I don't feel
comfortable I don't like what's
happening on the board I think probably
after I say like after I push it before
I was like uh this I'm probably slightly
worse
um and then
so I spent I think a long time thinking
here and I played Bishop D2 uh and I I
calculated this 94 variation
um and I thought here were you worried
about this queen to G5 uh no I thought I
could take on C6 and then after Queen
takes I might have the skin of king of
one and then I'll do like H4 H5 I mean
uh it's still like not so ideal because
if I play like g3 at any point my life
squares are very weak but it's still
possible absolutely yeah yeah still not
losing by any means still a lot of work
to be done for black on the open D and B
files good results so far for you and
tell us a bit about this game because
I'm sure you had your eyes on the Zoe
versus Carissa as well what did you
anticipate before the round to happen in
this one yeah I mean I'm not sure
because krissa plays the king's Indian
so it's like obviously going to be a big
fight
um so like I'm not sure I thought like
uh like when I was looking at the game
um Krista seemed to be I think slightly
better prepared she has actually like
almost twice as much time as Zoe does
yeah um and I thought like I'd probably
prefer to be black here although
um especially like just with the time
situation so I think um if actually of
course I went then I clinched so you're
feeling good about this one yeah I mean
I'm not sure what the objective
evaluation is but I think it's probably
easier for a person to play absolutely
if Zoe loses this one if she makes a
draw you still have to worry about the
tie breaks potentially you still have
some work to be done but if Carissa
manages to win you clinch the title yeah
well Alice great tournament so far good
uh pulling of the brakes today I have to
say great decision congratulations we'll
see you in the final round tomorrow
thank you quick question uh for you
Alice this is your fourth appearance in
the girls championships and obviously
you're coming into this champion ships
with a lot more confidence
uh tell us how you could compare your
rookie experience and what you are today
a veteran of the game yeah so I remember
like the first tournament I played in
actually I think was online
um so uh that was in 2020 and then two
years ago in 2021 I think that was
basically like my first video experience
and I think there I didn't do that well
I got like
um I just like lost a lot of games so I
mean I think um it's just like being
able to experience that even though I
didn't have particularly amazing results
the previous two years
um it was just like really good for me
to have this experience in playing in
this tournament so now I know like I
feel a lot more comfortable I guess
playing in this tournament
um compared to uh two years ago
just the feeling of experience and
comfort uh Alice uh big game tomorrow
good luck thank you absolutely as we go
around our horn and once again just
checking in on so we do have that whole
uh um
and I think for Zoe this is a real real
problem uh not easy it's I definitely
don't want to take I feel that all of
Black's pieces are in the play my Rooks
are still in the corner the Rooks are
centralized I feel like I'm 210p behind
and I must be clearly worse conversely
if I play E5 and we get into a position
for argument's sake just like this
I'm not happy either
trading the light score Bishops your
king can be also very weak on that
diagonal agreed agreed so I think
Carissa is really enjoying uh matters
let's continue
we haven't really checked in on this
very imbalanced position uh normally
speaking uh you know I look at
structures very very much that's like
the first thing I look at King's
positions and finally what pieces are
good and bad
catches your attention right yeah it
makes a very bad impression like why is
that night on B7 I I have to feel that
Rue Yang Yan is for Choice here I'm
going to go to the game between Rose and
Gracie for just a moment now here on the
other hand I see trumps for both players
right night on B3 some nice night is
going to come to F pardon me to G4 in
the very near future
this is wow okay this is just a little
bit uh crazy you need you need time to
understand this one what's happening
exactly I think both players have have
trumps we'll we'll keep an eye on this
one as we turn things over to Christian
Christian please don't lead us astray
I'm looking at the junior section by the
way uh that's Zoe versus Carissa is
completely winning for Carissa is it yes
at least according to the engines is
something along the lines of minus three
so Karissa is definitely looking
comfortable in that game and Alice you
know could be clinching today right and
you saw how excited she was about clean
she knew that you know with uh hiccup by
Zoe she's clinching this one you can
feel how much it means for her this
title take a look at this what's
happening in the ABI Manu versus Arthur
Zoo
and I'm looking at the engine and the
engine is telling me plus three the
position is still equal this engine
evals are a bit crazy G5 Bishop the idea
is that you have to go Rook to a six
first to uh put some pressure on the
night where is the night going you don't
have anywhere to move the Knight so you
have to drop with the Rook to C8 and now
I just simply go night wage for the
energy say plus 4.5 wow wow how is this
plus 4.5
right can somebody explain to me uh okay
I understand I have Queen to F3 I have
Knight takes G6 and something
landing on F7 and perhaps you just
simply don't have any way out this is
kind of crazy to me yeah
do we also have like Queen G4 just
trying to trade it Queens put the
pressure on Knight on C6 and then just
Rook B6 capture upon first probably also
away yes yes yes perhaps you have a lot
of ideas right between G4 G5 is on the
board so G4 followed by G5 abimanu
senses the urgency of this position and
by the way at this point if you don't go
G5 it's equal
huh it's very strange because I go
Knight to E7 right and then whenever you
go G5 I take on D5 first and then I drop
the bishop back so G5 taking away the E7
Square from the Knight Bishop to E7 is
forced and now Rook to A6 continue with
the pressure on black species and then
Knight to H4 this is the critical move
you cannot take on H3 because I take on
G6 and take on C6 next move I go Queen
to F3 and a lot of trouble is coming
your way Knight takes G6 and the F7 Pawn
Knight to F5 as well Queen to G4 the
idea that you mentioned uh Katarina as
well as maybe the doubling the simple
doubling on the a file and the capture
of the a file so Mishra looks like make
sure it's looking good he knows it he
feels it right now he's putting a lot of
pressure on Arthur Zoo who is indeed
struggling in this one uh it's uh again
eyes turning to to key games and I'm
looking at that matchup between Dimitri
gurvich and Alexander shabalov our
defending champion and when we left it
it it's this ironic moment after Knight
C5
if you're white and you're thinking
yourself I just want to get my king to
safety and you wanted to play the move
castles
I mean it's almost a puzzle Rush tactics
because I I'm just oh hold on why is
this different because now they're the
queen retreated and it's defending the
G2 oh we had seen it right I think we
had seen it maybe when it was here that
now I'm really confused yes how did we
go we said Castle it's a mistake because
and now yeah there was this uh beautiful
hidden tactic you don't often see this
uh threat of Checkmate on both H2 and G2
at the same time and you're done that's
it you're out uh so that was why in the
game Dimitri dropped back with this
queen defending the pawn on G2 uh Knight
C5 he's captured and we are caught up uh
with the players at this moment and Alex
hello doesn't care about his spawn on H7
so Dimitri can just capture I care
I care I don't know about uh uh Shabba
David okay if I take
King h8 and then I'm a little bit
worried about moves like Queen H4 check
so I'll get my Bishop out of Dodge I'll
go Bishop back now I can understand if
you want to play a move like D4 or
Knight H6 what do you think uh your Pawn
down yeah
um Queen H4 I don't like too much
because G3 is a bit of tempo it is it's
a it's a nasty tempo right
you're forced to move your queen on the
other hand hello hello there's some
Ambush uh going on yeah yeah
uh I'm not coordinated with white so I
feel there's a compensation but uh uh
help us out Christian uh the move Bishop
takes H7 check and Bishop F5 how does
the engine evaluate the pawn sacrifice
zero zero
but let's let's try to understand right
seven then Bishop to F5 sure Queen to H4
seems to be the best move you're trying
to create some weaknesses right you're
trying to open up the long diagonal so
that D4 comes at some point right G3
Queen to H5 take take white has to play
some precise moves as well and some very
concrete moves because otherwise again
it's D4 that's coming and your king is
in big big danger and you're King side
in general is in big danger in that
position so Castle right now this is not
easy stuff I have to say I'm looking at
the position I'm I'm looking at the
moves and this is not easy stuff because
in the absence of the light Square
Bishop you have so many weaknesses right
now and I can indeed transfer that
Bishop with the move Bishop to A6 you go
root to D1 Rook to E1 doesn't really
work because of Knight to D3 Rook today
8 followed by D4 you're still lacking
development in the position and it's not
that easy because Bishop to D2 for
example Rook Ada to go Bishop to D2 I
can go D4 I can go Knight to D3 I will
open up the position and once the long
diagonal opens up I can drop back the
bishop land the queen on F3 and the
Checkmate is coming so you have to be
very very careful with the white pieces
I'm looking at the position at least
from
a practical perspective with 29 minutes
only on the clock and this is move 12
guys right this is really early in the
game and you're running out of time in a
crazy complicated position despite the
fact that the engine is saying zero zero
up
it's so easy to make mistakes with white
exactly I have to say black has the
easier play sure I sacrificed upon but
it doesn't really matter this is the
typical of gay right this is these are
the type of tactics the type of patterns
that he tries in so
um I have to say I'm favoring Alexander
shabalov to maybe get the full point
home and
not force a tie break but uh force a
final round Showdown that's right
between himself and Malik said with
everything on the line that will be uh
very exciting indeed talk about talking
about
uh running out of time the game between
Andrew uh hung and Josiah
um okay it's a nice normal uh position
until you turn and look at the clock
right Andrew's down to like is the last
10 minutes or so Josiah's got much more
than an hour and that was that crazy
game with F7 F6 things have actually
would have done pretty well for black
when we left it we left it at these
parts we just seen the moves Bishop A7
yeah Andrew had a possibility to just go
for a draw here repeating moves the
tournament the the position in the
tournament required him to play for when
he took Bishop B5 there was a trade
we're quickly catching up to the players
the queen feels a little bit
uncomfortable on A5 but on the other
hand if in the way of A5 A4 uh hanging
in there Josiah Stephen just playing so
fast one hour and 20 minutes on his
clock the one thing I I think white does
have going for him is that if you can
play F4 F5 try to crack the center as
long as the center remains in place you
know this is what Andrew is looking at
exactly exactly
take over Christian uh this no why is
Josiah playing so fast you think he
still may be prepped no no no no way
here no way this is not prep maybe he
knows some ideas but definitely not prep
okay
um
wife has a couple of options F5 is a big
one now the more tame one and perhaps
even the more precise one is just Knight
to E4 try to exchange sometimes try to
make the position a bit more simple
Knight takes E4 Bishop F1 okay wait a
minute
uh I'm if you're gonna trade pieces
maybe the reason I didn't want to do
this is I really didn't want to give up
the square but uh Rook E8
whoops pardon me Rook B5
I do have a check right it does set up
some traps Bishop F1 on the board like
this move
Bishop F1 I'm really worried about the
White Queen exactly trapped if it just
it it feels like you're setting yourself
up for some
horrifying tactic
the very near future like I mean I'm
thinking about some like C4 sacrificing
about I don't like this motion of this
file specifically because of this reason
C4 is the move that plays itself right
and then you see Bishop C4 and you see
Queen C6 and you're saying I'm winning
well wait wait wait wait wait wait
hold on
there's something happening there
exactly there's something happening
there maybe not Knight takes D5
immediately maybe I can start with the
move A3 but yes that is
the critical idea behind this behind
Bishop F1 behind this whole position yes
there's always tactics on D5
so going back
and by the way
Josiah needs to realize this Andrew
needs to realize this
instead of Bishop after Bishop to F1
instead of C4 so can I do like Queen C6
just to prepare it that's one way the
best move is King h8
okay I
I don't know about that
it's the depths that there is like it's
not happening that's not gonna be no no
way no King AJ that is deep and Too Deep
absolutely
uh funnily enough I I mean I would
probably just drop back and say okay you
drop back with your Bishop I'll drop
back with my Rook what's your Bishop
doing well there's some problems with
that right is there yeah if you go to B6
maybe Knight A4 one is you're putting
your pieces it's funny I I see a move
like Bishop F1 I see a move like Knight
A4 and I'm thinking to myself my
opponent doesn't understand chess he's
putting his pieces off sides
you know I I mean maybe I have some
tactics though that's the problem you
may very I may be falling for some nasty
let's say I go right now
maybe just a simple Bishop G2 back or
Bishop H3 okay again I'm kind of patting
myself on the back saying okay that's
cool uh you like C4 a moment ago I
really like yeah you probably like it
even more with the Rook on C6 now that
you've got uh
the A3 is not protected by the queen uh
interesting uh game for sure if you
don't mind you said to me Carissa
was really a ahead Big Time according to
the computer and again that's a huge
game for our girls and oh well Zoe did
play a move by the way she she thought
she did not captured upon it no she did
play Rook D1
uh I'm sensing danger
I'm seeing D5 D4 oh pardon me D4 now we
understand why she put the Rook on she's
got she's got her plan oh that's a nasty
trap
Zoe well hold on help me out here Kate
can we take on e4
take on e4 right right and we take on e4
and now just because you were telling me
this diagonal could be an issue right
and here we can imagine very easily a
moment where check would be a terrible
move
um
okay so what's happening uh can we play
D4
yeah
that is the money move but it's not easy
because of the line no C3 I'm just
thinking like if we capture on e4 we are
actually going to be maybe in trouble as
black right Knight captures and why this
problems say trouble I'd say you're fine
I mean you're not worse not worse but
like white is okay right white probably
gone away fine fair so D4 is the move
that is kind of pushing for okay for
more for more and then after Knight B3
now we take on e4 we will take only four
let's let's be
aggressive with the bishop with the
bishop create some immediate threats yes
okay we take Knight takes C4 Knight
takes E4 and a moment ago I took with
the Knight maybe I should
try to get rid of this monstrous Bishop
Bishop takes D4 yes and this is the key
this is what what creason is calculate
up at this point and see this uh
brilliant move Knight D5 yeah I was just
thinking about that move actually Knight
D5 putting more pressure looking at E3 I
was yeah I was doing like reaching
across the board like uh Justin you know
like no no and I have to
I have to get out of she took right no
she played D4 no she took she took an E4
did Carissa look taking on e4 is the
more natural move
um D4 you have to calculate you have to
calculate a lot right but taking on e4
and uh Zoe by the way I think she had
this realization or or kind of an
awareness like something had gone wrong
she took back on e4 With You Know
Glee like I think she's feeling like the
worst is behind her right I mean out of
the opening there were some big big
issues and now I feel like Zoe is
slightly getting back you know into the
game into the game and why is it why are
we watching these uh two games so
closely very important for standing in
the U.S girls junior is the game between
Zoe tang and karisaib because if tank
loses Alice Lee wins the tournament
right and in the senior section if
shabalov doesn't win then melecation
actually wins the tournament so we have
these crucial two games and the crazily
good point is if Shabba does win his
game Guess Who he gets to play tomorrow
to actually fight for the title
it's the streetwriters guys absolutely
absolutely that's the reward that you
actually have it in your hands in the
last round right if you win the game
right now I always I always love that
personally is I hated being in those
situations where I had to rely upon
somebody else to do something for me
make a draw make a win whatever I loved
it when Destiny was in my hands and we
will hopefully that fight tomorrow may
decide the outcome between Malik said
and Shabbat where would you like to take
Escape I want to look around maybe in a
girls Championship to the other games
what's happening which Michelle was the
crazy game Let's jump to Rochelle we
just left it a moment ago and by the way
when we left it I was sitting there kind
of suggesting Queen D5 Rook B8 Bishop E2
Bishop D1 yeah what's the problem let me
take the pawn yeah but I was surprised
if we can take it like two minutes back
if
Bishop E3 yes I was wondering can we
just go D5 write a hat
why not absolutely giving up the C5 Pawn
I think in both as in the game we may be
transposing because in fact Rochelle did
capture on C5 Okay so let's go it might
be it might just be a transposition
because it in the game Knight C6 Bishop
takes C4
and you can play D5 I don't think you
really want to allow white to play a
move like Queen to D6 and then stop so
let's take a look at D5 and then how
would you
evaluate uh the position again where a
piece ahead for these really menacing
looking pawns that are ready they're
running forward they are I mean the
other on C3 uh hello uh this is not what
I would call a stable blockade either I
mean working on E1 very weak right I
like Rook B8 move to be honest as well
instead of D5 yeah I feel D5 is more
straightforward but I look just
developing the pieces on open files
Rooks that's always something we want to
do
what am I supposed to do I don't know
Kate I'm not I'm not a happy camper oh
you allow me to give the check yeah but
because I have rugby too also that
you can I'm I was hoping that I would be
able to deal with that I don't know how
moving the bishop
[Music]
I'm frightened yeah let me wait with
this rugby I think this is still very
strong but okay if I first check yes oh
sorry uh no what you want to play Queen
D6 I yeah I don't give a check okay can
you have two yeah and just 25 I Will
Wait
Queen F5 if you will wait
I'm not away why do I have to suffer
what is this it must be bad karma
because I'm threatening even C2 right
right now I I may have to pull a James
Bond uh out of my hat here and
go on the attack you know I I may be out
gone you know 20 to one but you know
historians are gonna call me heroic wow
but that's a very nice move I did not
see that one coming uh
I tricked you I I did not I don't like
Rochelle's position after you know that
Rook B2 business what you said but you
did give me that shot still careful yeah
right wow uh by the way we do have a few
moves on the board let's let me just uh
refresh my board so we can catch up with
the players because it seems to me like
Kelsey's doing everything right she just
played Rook B8 Bishop E2 Queen you know
that is a nasty nasty looking move right
the double threat rook and
Unstoppable
you know I I play chess these days for
fun but when even when I was playing
professionally I also like to play chess
for fun to enjoy chess I'm not enjoying
it
I would say you know if this was team
chess I would like invite you in and say
it's your turn I'm tagging in you may
refuse to tag in you know I refuse it I
reside at that point I don't want to
have to deal with this absolutely not
he's gonna she's completely lost no
right d5d for the Space Invaders are
coming and it's reminiscent of what
happened
um in Maxim glugy versus acopian right
very very similar this Pawn storm in the
center I mean this is just such a
celebration the best movies like Queen
C2 I mean if you have to do queen C to
exchange the queens and then face the
music with response coming your way give
you basically have to find the best way
to give the piece back right that's
exactly apparently this is the way to do
it right but it's not encouraging it's
not fun
Rochelle something happened because I
mean remember she had an hour and 33
minutes on her clock right and what
Kelsey was doing was just simply
following one of the only game in that
position right when she took on c for B
take C4 I think it was that move and
then Rochelle started thinking and
immediately made a huge blunder
that took her from more or less slightly
worse maybe slightly worse maybe equal
with a strong engine to a losing
position she played that move F4 Knight
F3 that
erroneous plan right so
I have to say there was just simply
something wrong in this game with
Rochelle's preparation something went
very very wrong agreed wholeheartedly
and just reinforcibly reminded of a an
event that took place here at the St
Louis chess club in Scholastic Center it
was these ultimate moves and there was a
team of people you know like Magnus is
on the team with Wesley which is on the
TV Carlos Rex and Randy and somehow
there was a rotation where completely
lost position and Gary kasparo
was horse
I was like I was going to accept this
resignation come on Gary please
but that's the way I feel after this
move by Kelsey uh this last move uh d uh
five it looks great for black and again
let's just jump to uh yeah we have that
that position between Dimitri gurvich
and Alexander shabalov they've followed
the line Dima crap captured the pawn on
H7 Bishop takes H7 check King h8 uh
Bishop F5 G3 and we do have Queen H4 on
the queen H5 pardon me on the board let
me just once again refresh my board
and no
we don't no so that was our enough that
was our analysis eight seven but nature
so instead decided to Castle not Captain
keep it safe just get the king to safety
and continue on the game is the king
safe over there though let's say let's
just have some fun let's take take Queen
out right you've got to play H3 and let
me just
pause this for a moment ah Knight E4
right so I'm thinking this threatening
mate I was thinking this this beautiful
Ambush and I was going to capture this
Knight if nothing else that there is the
movement before Oh man very good
resource for a while
yeah but I feel like uh like I got a red
face uh after the move 94 myself so
there is no immediate uh
kill going on there but on the other
hand too I can just simply capture and
play F6 and once again
important
yeah tomorrow key matchup so if shablo
does not win today and he needs that win
to get five and a half and therefore the
catch to try to play win against Malik
and get to that playoff to maybe as a
returning Champion together champion
title again yeah to defend his title
that will be very nice and again he's in
a situation he must win uh as black
against Dimitri gurvich there was a game
that had our attention in our first
broadcast and that was a game between
Douglas root and Gregory kaidana
sacrificing two pounds pieces everything
to upon sacrifice with the gambits and
then came this absolutely key moment E6
check and should we capture this pawn
and allow F5 F6 Gregory thought it was
wiser to duck that question and he does
allow these two very very powerful pawns
to maintain to remain on the board and
we're catching up with the players he
gave back upon
but I gotta tell you Doug's play has
been pretty impressive uh thus far
so what's the material balance it's two
pieces for a room and that's it no point
with the yeah but it's these ponds are
on these incredible squares so this one
is over this one where you can just
resign right because Knight D6
yeah
and combinations As Natural as a baby
smile uh Queen D7 so let's at least have
Sun counter poking Queen G5
so rookie two going back or check
if you want to wait with that check
rookie too okay Bishop F3
let's close our eyes
and remind a little bit okay on a good
day if I get to play Knight F6 well
Queen C7 okay
I still have to be careful right it's
not
that simple is it or
I mean I first impressions are that
white was doing great I'm just I'm
trying to confirm that the firm First
Impressions were accurate
there is uh one thing that I find myself
attracted to check right so if you go
King H7 and if you go rookie two I've
I've set up a trap
[Applause]
Queen trade with a check and then
capturing the bishop for free exactly
exactly exactly
um well that that's a double-edged super
sharp game let's go to a couple of the
games we haven't seen others uh just
checking in on Joel Benjamin uh versus
uh Vladimir copian again these two
players great great Legends of the game
how are they matching up with one
another
a little bit of a crazy fight going on
here
first impressions are well blackies
right extra opponent E6
yeah White's looking at I mean White's
looking to
play the move Bishop B3 right if I can
play Bishop B3
maybe I'm going to be winning upon back
I can go now Knight D4
oh
grab that night if you want to but there
is still this
I mean be careful
of uh check doctors offering uh nights
uh you might be uh yeah I'm intimidated
from night to default but I do have
Bishop D1 and now I'm okay a
double-edged game uh and finally another
game we didn't really get a chance to
look at Max delugie versus Igor novikov
we've got again Bishop's about opposite
colors but black people and up wow uh
something to play for here for Igor and
over to you Christian you've been
anxiously waiting to tell us about
balaji's uh nice position oh well
I've actually been anxiously waiting to
tell you that Kirk is just uh playing
incredible practical chess and maybe
maybe he's not out of danger yet but
he's definitely putting on a fight an
incredible fight take a look at this
after Queen 24 not Queen takes A4 of
course that's too easy right okay I'm
going to go c3c2 if you put the reconsi
to the bishop B2 line that we discussed
game over right right you have to this
is panic mode you have to do something
you have to create something in the
position despite of the objectivity of
everything that's going to be happening
Queen to E4 was the move that he made at
this point Bishop to D5 wins wins on the
spot but you need to calculate a few
more moves Queen to F4 or queen to H4
attacking the pawn on F6 you continue
with C3 you give me one more move we
signed the score sheets I go C2 right
but now you're starting to see Bishop to
E5 there's amazing threats happening
right you need to calculate and this is
it you cannot be lazy in this type of
situations and it's very easy to fall
into that trap it's very easy to just
make the first move that you see without
calculation without actually going deep
into the lines if Balaji would have
stopped he would have seen this because
it's not that difficult Rook to f8 you
put a queen anywhere first of all
there's no more Bishop to E5 there's no
more battery against uh the King on G8
on Long diagonal and after Rook to F5
next move I play C2 and it's it's over
right first of all did I just trap your
queen I think I just
that was a present yeah correct right
you you see this you calculate this this
is game over
he didn't go for that he went for the
simple simple looking Bishop to F5 right
I'm going for your Exchange
Queen to H4 G5 I'm going to first cover
I'm playing it safe Balaji is playing it
safe right now but maybe it's not enough
take a look at this poking right the E6
Square Queen to H3 very good move by the
way perhaps something that Balaji missed
from the farm now you have to drop back
well if you drop back I go E4 now I
closed you up a little wow C3 is not
coming that easy because I take on a B5
you have your own things that you need
to worry about in the position Queen to
C6 and in fact right now after D5 the
engine is saying Kirk is back in the
game wow he's still worse but he's back
in the game remarkable he's not losing
by force by any means you have to really
make the best moves Queen to E8 is the
best move then the engine is saying -1.7
Kirk is once again finding a way back
into the game we've seen him do that
yesterday he was completely busted out
of the opening he's doing it again when
great fight with tenacity with
resilience this is exactly what we're
seeing right now and it's a lesson that
anybody that's watching and any aspiring
player needs to definitely pay attention
to this is something that's so
impressive for me because everyone can
kind of sometimes outplay your opponent
and play like good chess but to be
making sure that even in the worst
position you try to hang on be very
resourceful try all that there is not to
lose the game I think that's a very
tough skill to happen yeah I agree
wholeheartedly if you can improve your
tenacity your thou shall not pass and
you will just defend positions I
understood that I became a good player
when my opponents had to play very well
to beat me that was when I realized for
the first time like I'm decent like my
opponents had to play well because my
tenacity I was putting up counter play
you know putting and what Kirk found and
this I thought it was busted I thought
Queen A4 you're done dusted uh next game
but uh he's fighting he's fighting very
very well I wanted to go to mishra's
game as well as the game of Arthur guo
two of our well tournament leaders when
we left it we really liked what Mishra
played G5 Bishop E7 Knight H4 this and
Kate that follow-up position where you
suggested the move Queen Chief I love
that Queen G4 just cementing control
over the FI Square all the white species
the bishop on D5 fantastic
completely uh domination uh Bishop f8
Queen F3 I liked your queen G4 Queen F3
Queen E8 and Mishra although its
positions really dominant sometimes
you just gotta win right like and uh so
basically Arthur is saying okay I agree
I agree I I'm not happy uh but where's
the Breakthrough show me the
Breakthrough do you see is it clear for
you how you would continue the game I
mean I kind of understand what Arthur is
doing right now E7 and trying to capture
that bishop or push the pawns to kind of
get some kind of break exactly exactly
but that Bishop on D5 is Frankly
Speaking just too good you gotta you
gotta play 97 so that was why I was
asking if you if you saw
a kill do you like Knight F5 do you like
Knight I mean if you could play Knight
G6 and H5 in one turn that'll be nice
you're all you're you're gung-ho but I
like neither five
and again I'm
I I don't know I'm not I'm not a happy
camper sorry but I'll take that and my
intention is however you recapture to
play 97. I'm looking at this position by
the way and I just
despise my position I don't mind yeah
it's like these pawns even though
they're doubled uh it feels a positional
grip right and even if the Knight
captures the bishop now on D5 Queen
recaptures right we have some F4 tricks
oh
yeah I'm looking at this and I think
Mishra is in great position let's go to
the game of Jason uh Liang and Arthur
when we left it we had seen the the the
position after C7 C6 I liked Jason's
position I thought Arthur was the one
who was going to have to suffer a little
bit Knight to D4 all so far so good Rook
C8 Rooks C5 Rook E1 Rook C8
okay that's a little confusing move why
didn't we play Rook F3 I I guess I guess
he was afraid of Rook too just capturing
sacrifices Knight F5 yeah there's some
there's some first rank back rank issues
for white as well Rook to G3
Queen E7 okay so I cannot play Knight F5
now even though it looks very pretty
because the Rooks Duro can simply
capture it and I'll look on E1 is going
to be lost that's that's
embarrassing that's that that's awful we
don't want that to happen maybe Queen F3
Queen A3 happened
Queen A3 everyone I'm not sure if I
understand what is what's going here I
somehow I think in those last sequence
of moves Arthur our tournament leader is
actually also like her kind of fought
his way back into the game and I'm
thinking that the Rook on G3 if you
don't land and attack The Rook can just
simply be misplaced uh from Arthur's
point of view you know he gets to post
up in the center with Rook C1 and queen
E5 he'll be just fine clock's a factor
by the way or not really both players
have 30 minutes uh wait
am I no let me check it again oh okay no
I'm incorrect Jason Young has 37 minutes
and Arthur go 22. so white has you know
15 minutes Advantage oh okay and again
crucial game for our tournament
standings and over to you Christian jump
uh jump in and what has caught your eye
well let's stay within the Juniors okay
and see what's happening in this one
Justin versus Brandon Jacobson because
again Brandon is pretty close uh to the
leaders right only half a point behind
uh Gua so take a look at this position
Queen to D3 and this in fact stopped
Brandon because for I think for around
30 minutes he thought for his next move
yes he has a lot of options right the
question is how are you going to stop my
push with B6 potentially on the queen
side Rook fb8 was one of the ways taking
on B5 was another one and Knight to E6
which was the chosen way uh was another
very very good move obviously the idea
is pretty clear you want to put the
Knight on C5 if you do go B6 as white
I'm going to control that pawn with the
move Knight to uh C5 then I'm going to
Corral it Rook ba Queen da or Rook to A6
you don't don't have the dark Square
Bishop to find a way to defend this Pawn
on B6 and this would be very very good
for black in fact maybe even decisive
close to decisive for black so he played
the move Knight to B3 taking control of
the C5 square and we have C takes B5 C
takes B5 Knight to F4 that is the
problem this Knight on E6 has a almost a
double threat a double duty in the
position maybe I will control the B Pawn
as I've uh showed with Knight C5 or
maybe I will keep an eye on the attack
as well with the move Knight to F4 this
is what we have right now Queen to D2
Bishop to E6 I have to say I'm looking
at the position Queen takes D6 is on tap
is this something that he missed no the
rook and Rook A3 right this is the big
question yeah
sorry Rook C8 Rook C6 right and then I
attacked the Rook Bishop D7 Bishop D7
Aha and then I take take and I'm hoping
at the end of the day there's a
nighttime B6 maybe this is what he
missed wow that's running straight
forward no way
super complicated oh my goodness it
seems like Queen takes D6 might in fact
work in the position that's crazy Queen
D6 take take Rook C8 still the best move
Rook C6
we just have to take take on E2 and then
go Rook to C8 or Rook to A6 is the only
way to recapture that but that's a draw
and that's that's a draw yes yes you're
not winning this obviously uh and even
this is not that clear wait a minute
what what in the world is this ah you
have an idea here at the end not easy to
calculate really not easy to see all of
this stuff not at all and by that and
he's going approaching for it
maybe he missed wow oh my goodness yeah
I think he played this move a night away
for a bit too fast or Bishop Bishop was
the last move yes by the way sorry to
interrupt our discussion here Andrew Han
went down to 10 seconds yes speaking
about difficult what's difficult it's
playing when you are only on increment
and your opponent has one hour and you
have difficult position and that's
exactly what's happening in the game
between Andrew honk and Josiah Stillman
we did uh Josiah just dropped back with
his Rook kind of a move that you know
the Lazy Man's move let's put it like
that uh F5
wow that takes and look at this Andrew
said gift me the pawn Knight takes and
C4 well that white king is exposed
Bishop F7 takes oh here I was expecting
something spectacular receiver can we
have someone Queen F6 is a nice move
kind of targeting the diagonal exactly
Queen A1 a threat and the bishop will
also uh
pop-up if you will on the G6 Square
rookie 3 Rook B4 okay reinforcing some
ideas of Queen A1 Queen takes A6
grabbing pong oh my gosh okay I'm a pond
grubber but this I would uh I would
hesitate
uncomfortable and brand well look at the
Andrew but just as played Rook E1 we've
caught up with the players tell me again
about the clock times so the clock is
crazy so we see uh Andrew Hong really
having 50 49 seconds so he is playing on
the increment and Josiah's steamer
Steelman one hour two minutes so much
time to think but he's trying to you
know keep the pace to to force Andrew
maybe into a mistake when you buy when
you said steamer you forcibly reminded
me of the Stanley Steemer I think we now
have we we we have a label for Josiah
the steamer what do you think uh uh
Christian can it go viral I don't know
we'll have to ask him about that okay um
what's what's the uh his situation to a
worse position actually Andrew is
defending this very he's on the back
foot right but he's defending it very
accurately and in fact uh this right now
seems to be just simply better for white
the question is okay so we go rookie
eight right rookie does that work just
brutal for us okay it may be Queen
wait a minute
H4 is an option as well because the idea
is you're on this diagonal but you don't
have H6 but I can take on E3 right yeah
but is this no no
okay uh
and the the bishop on F1 is under my
protection
oops sorry anything here in this
position and so then you're fine no this
is great this is good for uh for white
or white that's what was my impression
too so I thought either Rook E4 or Rook
E8 I was
anticipating to meet either of those
moves with so I I thought okay Josiah
needs to come up with another shot here
maybe as simple as Bishop takes D5 and
just play the position a pawn down but
with right no he's missing out his last
few moves but they were not very
accurate
chance yeah somewhere because Queen F6 I
really like that me too me too well it
sounded like the right move right right
Rook to E3 and now I think Rook to B4 he
played which was a good move that was a
good move and queen takes A6 and now
Queen to d8 was the best move
but I understand we are kind of playing
or threatening Rook A8 Rook 8 is one of
them I think very crucial is to in fact
uh first of all control the eighth rank
but also control the D6 Square for the
queen as well as imagine I go C4 at some
point yeah and then you take with the
bishop and I take back I exchange I
sacrifice The Exchange and you take back
with the queen so that you don't allow
me my rookie
so the queen on d8 is in fact very
powerful very potent in the position
that's a remarkable move it wasn't on my
agenda Queen G5 looked attractive but
maybe it was shallow to my eyes the most
attractive sequence was in fact Queen A1
yes and that's why I don't understand
why he didn't stop and and think in this
position okay Bishop G6 Bishop D3
everything is forced another D4 right
yeah yeah the desirable Queen takes G6
is met by Queen takes A2 but Bishop to
G6 and then Queen to D4 uh from a visual
perspective this is the most Force this
is the most you know you centralize the
queen it's nice right it looks nice
right but okay once again are we getting
yes rookie one and then you will have to
calculate C4 but that's the thing I mean
look you have an hour on the clock
you've got to calculate these things
exactly this is a wild position there's
so many crazy things happening uh and in
the current position though we think uh
Andrew despite his very very uh great
shortage of of time is simply better and
this is the one thing that it's so
difficult to
um adjust and manipulate during a game
what do you do when your opponent has 30
seconds runs down to his last few
seconds in a wild position with a naked
King as we see in this one what do you
do you have an hour on the clock do you
stop and think for as long as you need
to make sure that the variation that
you're going to play is correct or do
you just like try to Blitz out play into
your opponent time travel and maybe risk
a little bit it's a big dilemma that you
have to answer In the Heat of the battle
Yeah for me I try to find the wildest
most craziest complicated stuff I can
and see if I can set some traps and
snares for my opponent
um I always try to do the one with
Brilliance or baffle them with nonsense
yeah no I totally start to focus on
putting actually like good chess like if
I if I need to take more time I don't
try to flag my opponent I just want to
make sure I'm making good moves you
can't always play good chess sometimes
you gotta Bluff a little that's what
he's doing that was his decision too
often for me but one yeah good chance
this is your prescription please
I like really Carissa's move move 23
Knight C4 I thought it was a really cool
move if we go back and we're we're up to
this is this double-edged stuff we
thought that Carissa was for Choice Rook
to D3 and it's Knight C4 love it so we
are kind of looking at you know E3
Square so 40 if you would want to go 95
not to trade the right Square Bishop
sure I simply take that night with the
bishop however you recaptured and I have
this Knight E3 well that's that's
embarrassing that's a that's a terrible
uh a denouement uh my queen is uh but I
love this move Knight C4 because again
you ask your piece what are you doing
the Knight on D6 says I want to get in
the game and I like your E3 but and
there's I guess well just Bishop takes f
3 and Knight takes B2
my eye
I uptake C6 Queen takes C6 and like you
say Knight takes B2 not happy uh for Zoe
here but just a second is there
um well the problem is
I don't have a really good should you
play Rook HD1 which is a very logical
move you just develop The Rook what did
she do sir Rook HD one in this current
position yeah okay now Karissa captured
on F3 yes
and played Queen C6 I see that right
okay and that pin is unpleasant to say
the least
three Knight takes B2 also on tap so
Rook to D3 Zone very nice move your
Zoe's hanging on there that's where
targeting that B2 is not functioning
right now yeah it doesn't work right
okay so far so good but you know still
Zoe's being tied up if you will she does
have one idea on her agenda I think the
move Knight to D5 okay we still have to
be careful about Knight E3 right there's
there's always that discovered attack
true okay so uh how to how to uh
continue and I know that white doesn't
want to do it but the pawn on A7 is
hanging let's just say
right doesn't want to you you'll be
surprised she might be reaching
um okay but Carissa she Carissa has the
momentum on her side but now she has to
find something the B5 do you like that
or you just want to hide the bishop I'm
thinking to take
um not that I'm that uh in enamored if
you okay what's the idea well the idea
of course was to drop in on E2 uh my
problem is if you take with a rook
Diego Rook to d8 oh we haven't moved
yeah no I'm not happy uh that that
recapped I thought B5 could be a
possibility to just try to go and push
the pawn but okay Carry Supply Rook CDA
I think if I'm in White Shoes I'm
aspiring for the move Knight D5 I'm
hoping that that move will
give me but the problem is 95 don't I
have Knight E3 and is isn't that in-game
completely busted so let's say I'm a
sacrifice because B5 B5 was good I like
okay oh B5 yeah so B5 Knight B5 Knight
D3 Knight E3 check I have to recapture
with that nice to take on C2 take on C2
and this does look like an axle
excellent position it's just that pin is
so annoying right but wait can you Can
you capture it Rook on each
just Rooks D takes E3
and the Knight takes F6
ah thank you you can definitely do that
but I don't think I have to take the
queen I think I can take on D5 whoops
you take on D5 well now and by the way
okay you know what I'll call your Bluffs
I just realized it's a bluff
you know
tell me only correct play wait a minute
I'll call your block I'll take on seat
too so go Kings f8
King fa
no more bluffing
wait a minute wait a minute I I I I I I
I've been disrespected on every level I
tell you what's going on here uh she
didn't play B5 she uh I understand
Carissa karissa's saying you've got one
potential idea of uh getting your
getting out of trouble I'm gonna stop
you with the move rook d8 and by the way
uh Zoe it's clock times yes
10 minutes she played B3 and
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa my spidey sense
is tingling is there
The Rook on F3 being pinned it's a lot
of
kind of thing wait a minute wait can I
play Knight a
8 don't capture the rook and capture
tonight
okay let's take a look see so Knight A3
I moved my queen yeah what if
okay did you want to capture I want to
capture Queen takes
wait sorry you wanted to capture on D3
yes you're right I heard you and then
I'll recapture oh but I still cannot
tell you because that's I mean at the
end of the day well Rook d8 yes Rook d8
now right now okay
um and I've got to maintain
um defense maybe Queen E4 actually oh
thank you uh I was blind queen E4 okay
that's a nice okay to get out so the
current position is right here and it
feels like there ought to be some kind
of a shot for black
I mean because again you know this pin
awkward let's say I go
where can I go can I go Knight B2 okay
wow just trying to be creative what
about the Creator what about the correct
chest night V2 wow that's a visual okay
so explain to our audience if Luke takes
I recapture with the rook and when you
take the Knight yes D3 that's nice and
I'm keeping that pain I want to
recapture with Rook on C3
and that's a super comfortable position
no that that would be a joy Knight B2
okay that's kind of hitting me from the
side if you will unexpected
I like it it gets even more crazy if you
move Farooq E3 Rook D2 E3 I will capture
that Rook yeah you capture with bishop
and I will play Knight D1 I will jump
around that's nasty Queen takes C3 you
had me a queen C3 but Knight D1 is a
kind of a visual as well
um
and just to remind our viewers if you're
joining as light shame on you but these
are some really important games Kate
very important game we are looking at
Zoe tank game against Carissa yet
because if Zoe Tang loses this game then
Alice Lee wins the tournament and she is
grounded as the U.S junior girls
champion
the next thing we are looking at is uh
Alex chabalov playing with Dimitri
gorevich because if shabolov doesn't win
then Medics had catching with his
fantastic game in this tournament wins
the tournament
wow and we're gonna take a break as
these uh games are in full swing we'll
see you on the other side of our brain
[Music]
hi everyone we are here at the 15th
anniversary of Saint Louis chess club in
Central West End it's also International
Chess Day there is a lot of fun going on
behind us let's go check that out
[Music]
foreign
tastic day so we have a beautiful
weather and then there are so many
players here even from the like U.S
juniors seniors girls we are playing
Dark Chess By the way you can see my
face paint and it's so fun to see all
the players yesterday is playing Dark
chess even Josiah still and Karissa if
everybody here so it's really fun to to
be just experiencing chess we have a lot
of kids here we have a lot of adults a
lot of Club players so I think
everybody's really enjoying the chess
atmosphere celebrating 15th anniversary
of the club and I mean it's just really
fun I think everybody who started this
formation of the St Louis chess club it
has truly been a great advancement to
the game of chess especially in this
country and I'm just so excited to be
here and play all like just chess with
other people who do as well I'm just so
happy and so elated
[Music]
wow what does a club mean to me well it
changed my life if I wasn't doing the
commentatory I'd be watching
so now I've got the best job in the
world I've got a front row seat
I get to mingle with the chess players
and I get to watch the greatest games in
the world unfold in front of me and it's
been a life-changing and the most
rewarding experience my chess crew
I'm 15 years older and I'm still here
that's pretty good
now I see what it is I realize we have
such an incredible staff like you guys
that it's just remarkably successful
there's no question it's the best club
in the country if not the world
yeah
it was a wonderful day full of fun
celebration and ice cream I Just Want to
Thank You Saint Louis chess club for
amazing 15 years happy International
Chess Day
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's Grandmaster William
tokorchonova I will be doing social
media for the U.S Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen singfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the national championships
we have a few results with our
leadership right so in the round eight
in the U.S girls junior Championship we
have one draw between Alice Lee and
Harry small the youngest participants in
this tournament splitting the halving of
the point but our leader in the seniors
Malik said also also Malik sirkachan
against Patrick Wolf one draw in this
tournament which means our results are
pardon me our standings are so let's
take a look at standings for the U.S
junior Championship we have a soul
leader Arthur go with Five Points
closely followed by Brandon Jacobson and
abemano Mishra with four and a half
points indeed and let's just jump into
those games of Arthur and Brandon and
Amisha so when we left it we left this
uh game of Arthur just about this point
and I had kind of been suggesting well
shouldn't we be playing Rook uh to see
Wanda try to take advantage of the back
rank because after all this Rook on G3
could be misplaced if the attack doesn't
pan out I'm not a fan of the move G7 G6
Queen A1 Jason discovered covered his
back rank Knight G7 B4 forcing The Rook
to move away from C5 I kind of like this
I like what's going on here drop back
Knight F3 just checking just checking my
Spidey Sense was tingling there Knight
F5 I think you take you take take and
then play Rook C1 so Knight F3 defends
The Rook by the way I am setting up now
I am ready ready to play the move Knight
F5 F7 F6
whoa Knight thanks too
okay Arthur is being challenged because
guess what this movement Knight G4
H6 is going to be a Target A6 is going
to be a Target but F5 right after wait
wasting no time just pushing the Rook E3
we've caught up with the players as the
clocks are the clocks a factor uh
11 minutes on the clock uh I'm not a fan
of Black's position I don't know if it's
if it's really really bad it's really
really bad that's what I'm thinking that
it could be easily really really bad
let's say I play Rook F3 my idea besides
taking the pawn I really want to play
Knight G4 Knight H6 check as fast as I
possibly can and
tell us how bad is it uh Christian it's
just uh losing plus uh close to plus
three points Advantage for white why
with the Rook F3 yeah so Rook F3 that's
the move that's the money move what do
you do and he's played it on the board
Rook f8 very natural move right has he
played it yet no he hasn't no very
natural moment
yes let's see it okay and probably it
will come on the board right okay let's
just go ahead take a look and why once
again uh I quantify it for us it's once
again is not that clear with a naked eye
it's not that clear actually no and this
is probably very difficult to uh
understand and comprehend yes look at
Faith you just simply have to take on B5
and then go for
the B5 bar with Rook to D3 Rook to D5
Rook to D3 Knight to G4 as well if you
move the Rook from the f file it's
basically just
a never-ending Advantage for white
because I have the better pieces and I
have much more targets D6 is a target B5
is a Target and you don't have any
Targets but I have to say that decision
is very difficult you're attacking the
king and suddenly you're like wait a
second I want to grab your bishop and go
into an end game completely agree yes
yeah I'm a pond Grabber and uh that's it
they're saying yeah okay I'm like I'm
more anxious looking towards a king side
attack based on ideas of Knight G4 maybe
on a good day play E5 my Rook you know
jumps into the The Fray and I didn't
really see what black is gonna do if we
just go 94. okay I must confess that if
you just calmly take it step back for
just a moment imagine that it was my
move and I played Knight F3 now take a
look at your knight on G7
just tell me how you're going to get the
night into the game I can go night if oh
I cannot what am I yeah you just like
you start to think okay go to E6 and
then I can't go to C5 like I ca I go 96
I can't go to F4 I can't go to D4 I
can't go to C5 gosh mine you know what
can I go Rook C4
yes that's a good move also that's a
really good move but pardon me we have
yeah that's Rook C3 uh
okay so he did go Rook F3 yes he did go
Rook very natural move as I announced
and now
okay he now wants to put his Knight on
H2 to the F3 Square he's not he hasn't
convinced himself that the Knight on D4
isn't better than the bishop so he
played Rook to C3 jump in Christian you
said that's a very good move that's a
good move yeah yeah and the reason is
that if you go the very natural CA back
right yeah then I take consider on C7
okay what do you take back let's say I
take back that's the natural way right
yeah but now I go Knight G4
you oh you're back to oh yeah my G4 I'm
back to to the real business because
Knight also could potentially jump to F6
if I can pardon me if you make a move a
bad move very very bad move I can't I've
got a that is that is exactly the point
yes a nasty idea they're okay so again
our tournament leader
in big trouble pressure no I I have a
feeling we're going to see a change of
leadership in today's round after
today's round
because abhimanyu is winning his game
and at least he's in a much better
situation Brandon not so much Brandon
that one is probably going to end here
anytime soon I actually think that's
going to end very very soon by the way
if we can go back to Zoe tanks and
Carissa please do it because I really
like what Curry said you did she did
move Knight B2
a move that you had
uh drummed yeah before Knight B2 such a
nice move attacking The Rook
I must say if you don't mind you know if
you told me as a puzzle Rush tactic that
there's a moment here you know I I might
look for Knight B2 I might find it very
very quickly but it's not a move that
immediately comes to mind because you
know I'm thinking Rook takes right Rook
takes and I'm taking this Knight and
unless I follow it up with the
understanding that okay uh play another
move guys please jump why don't I get
the result anytime soon Douglas root is
breaking through against Kai Donald take
a look oh how pretty
ladies but take a look at this Rook to
d8 Rook to B7 and look at this nice
sequence Queen you take I take but hey
guess what the Recon B7 is dropping next
I'll be a rook up at the end of it this
is game over in Douglas root is getting
his second victory in a row against
kaidano I mean very big victory indeed
courageous display of play of Chess in
uh the opening phase I mean take a look
at that F5 get the pawn to E6 and right
now I mean he has it in the back
beautiful wow absolutely beautiful I
mean yesterday was very straightforward
today again wow well let's hear it for
the Gambit play again this seniors
playing like Juniors you know with this
Gambit Danish uh
and uh I'm being told by the way that
Dimitri and Alexander chavo's game
kind of balance actually and and there
is a handshake between Doug root and
Gregory kaidanoff as what a game
I mean he played well he saved his best
for last his last two games have been
fabulous incredible yeah this is a game
you will see in a magazine you know
annotated like that's one of my best
games right absolutely
well three words
fabulous
nice nice finish uh let me just jump
quickly to the Dimitri Alexander
shabalov game because that game uh is
racing to to a Finish Line a Finish Line
why is this a Finish Line well
G5
and now if I go you try for too much
then I go F6 and I have a feeling you're
in trouble not a feeling yeah I'm in big
trouble
I have to play Queen E5 you're sort of
four and now you play Bishop yeah this
is the repetition we see Queen takes E5
on the board
and we are expecting uh Dimitri to find
uh Bishop F4 well if he doesn't he's
upon down
but actually a couple of Pawns now by
the way is there any if I try to play
the game
no what am I saying I was I was about to
reach illegally for The Rook D3 maybe
Knight takes F5 right okay how do I get
yeah how could I continue I mean you can
go Knight to five and probably give me
the peace after Queen G4 or queen F4 and
play this m game Queen takes a five or
who takes a five but what's the body
count uh you have three parts you have
three pawns but they're not very mobile
uh at the same time look your shibalov
at this point you're starting to make
calculations do I play for second place
do I play and force things for first
place I don't know uh this is a three
result game for sure uh but maybe white
is for Choice by the way just to now
that I think about being a piece down
and for pawns and stuff the Zoe game
would and not pardon me not the Zoe game
but the uh Rochelle game where those
pawns were uh
descending in the position
we left it well we left it
hereish Ruby one we saw that and D5 and
yeah we thought oh
we didn't like Queen C2 Rochelle went
with G4
okay
Queen takes G4 now okay I'm a kind of a
pawn Grabber but something about just
hanging around in the center she took no
Queen C2 quincy queen trade but also you
got to get rid of this Rook this Rook is
oppressive uh Rook B3 Rook G1 Queen D F5
uh G7 wait what the ideas of Bishop H6
Rook takes G7 what well she's got I mean
look wait is it I'm very happy that I
have such a move as Rook G7 because I
can see that I'm going to resign as soon
as that lands and if I play F6 G6 so
let's go let's have some fun okay if I
capture it check let's go King h8
oh you're not supposed to be able to go
King hata I was going to go Knight G5
you weren't supposed to do that Kate
but if I know oh I don't have I wanted
to go Queen H3 okay
let me show what you might have
overlooked uh
wow uh your king might be going for a
bit of a hike
what do you think about these uh
things
uh
unfortunately I don't have the move
Bishop G4 check on my agenda
whoa some kind of complications that I'm
still probably happy with Rochelle
having some chances exactly that you do
have these chances but let me interrupt
our discussion as we have a special
guest in studio with Christian
absolutely a dog you saved the best for
uh last what an incredible game and
display of an attacking chess tell us
about this opening preparation oh well
uh we actually play and analyze this a
lot at my University Chester okay
so I thought I'd give it a try it seems
to pose a lot of problems for blacks
absolutely just to interrupt you for a
second I think these two players are
about to shake hands we see Shabbat
right now looking at the score sheets
probably checking whether it's a
three-time repetition
I have a feeling this one or
if by the way it finishes in a draw we
have a champion yes we do we have a new
senior Champion uh I I I think we're
just about to shake hands I think we
should uh stay with this moment right
here for a second
and uh the the the claim was wrong in
accurate come on somebody's getting them
in it it was inaccurate because the
queen on E5 was three times but in fact
once the bishop was on C1 instead of G5
oh my goodness okay come on well thank
you for that hey your your accuracy and
attention the detail is noted let's stay
with this by the Arbiters as well I
think we're gonna see two more moves in
another claim and
is going to be accurate actually Queen
F6 maybe
and that's it that gives us wow the
champion uh say our new 2023 Champion
wow congratulations Grandmaster Malik
said catching the new 2023 U.S Senior
Champion winning twenty thousand dollars
and very very well deserved yes yes yes
he got lucky in his game with Igor
novikov sometimes you but look at all
the other games that he won and he won
beautifully so our congratulations and
back to you congratulations Doug
I mean tell us once again this is
Collegiate prep yes I keep telling them
collegial chess is very serious and they
don't believe me this is Collegiate
level prep nice and tell us a bit about
this what if he takes this part uh then
F5 is usually best F5 and now uh what's
the best move does he have to just like
drop back uh he could play Bishop D7 or
Bishop C4 Bishop C4 then rookette four
and then like B5 Rook takes C4 okay some
crazy stuff yeah my goodness
okay you take Queen D5 and then the game
continues but and at Bishop D7 then
there's F6 so or queen maybe Queen H5 it
you can either play F6 immediately or
queen H5 and then F6 we were look
looking at this and there was this
position and then it's completely Rook
up four and whites it's equal it's more
or less Dynamic equality yeah right
there yeah it's a sharp position good
luck finding all the moves up until this
point that's right now uh my opponent
was uh I was amazed at how well and how
quickly he navigated through all of this
exactly because it's not easy right and
yeah I think is the best move at least
by yeah he's a great player and he
showed it early on unfortunately he
had problem a problem at the end he did
but I mean you were still keeping the
pressure going these two points are
always going to be extremely dangerous
no matter what happened and this was the
moment
yeah I probably should have played Queen
F7 check first I I don't know no no I
think did I play it right yeah yeah no
okay I think Queen to E4 was perhaps the
best move but even that is very
accomplished it remains very complicated
yeah Queen C5 E7
Bishop to C6 and now you're already
starting to take over Rook to d8 and
Rook to B7 yeah
Rook takes Queen E4 now I should just
play King AJ king h8 or King G8 yeah
either one what was your plan uh after
this move came to GA well I I can't play
King F1 because Bishop B5 check run uh
so that's a problem that's a check yeah
right
uh so I thought I'd probably have to
take the rook
and yeah you should be able to hold this
and then we played this position yeah
basically yeah he's not getting
checkmated no he did miss this EA yeah
and this is uh game over well Doug I
mean you started off slowly but finally
you're coming back in the tournament you
start a tournament it feels like you
want to start a tournament on you yeah
still one round to go who are you
playing tomorrow uh Patrick
still one big game to go guys any
questions congratulations Doug very very
nice back-to-back wins and good luck for
today tomorrow's game yeah
congratulations I have one question are
you a big fan of gambits because some
place really like it I used to play it
kind of when I was younger but then you
reach some strong level in chess and you
stop playing gambits but I still see you
really enjoying these crazy sacrifices
do you still play gambits a lot uh yes I
I enjoy some gambits and I also like to
play against Gambit sometimes
it's all about that Collegiate press
guys
go back to school yeah sir I'll give you
a zoo scholarship come back to school
congratulations Doug uh by the way we
also have a result
one she wanted it in a nice way remember
we were critical of this night on B7 it
never really well guess what it never
got into the game uh really and the
night was always kind of like this sore
thumb nice move right here night D4 oh
uh Discovery against the United attack
on the queen exactly and
finally just when black no Queen A4
really nice we're getting into that
second rank oops sorry yes Queen takes
as well as Queen D7 and shriya had seen
enough this was uh winning uh for her
Rochelle when we left she just played
Rook takes G7 let's see was it was it
Bluff
Rook takes G7
King takes G7 Queen takes but you know
the time Kelsey has less than three
minutes I'm still about 14 moves to make
for a Time control so even if it is a
bluff it is worth your shot I think in
this game exactly we got this position
on on the board and okay let's say I go
Queen H4 check okay let's try Queen H4
check I'm assuming I have to run for the
hill she won Queen H6 Queen H6 Check Yes
by the way
um Kelsey only down to her last minute
right still 13 moves to go
King E7
are you gonna take my knight I'm afraid
you might take I'm not really that
afraid of check I think I can keep
running but uh I'm afraid Queen G6 maybe
a bit more now yes I'm afraid I'm more
afraid of this one uh but the Rook C1
there will be one Europe B1 and I take a
bishop it it it's a mess it's a mess
Rochelle's trying to muddy the waters
can she do it uh well oh Christian sorry
you got that other game uh
no I it's it's busted completely busted
for Rochelle but Kelsey still has to
navigate this very carefully okay so
what if we go Queen G6 Queen G6 is the
best move yeah I like that move because
I'm forcing Queen trade I'm keeping my
knight I and I care about the night more
than I care actually about my Rook on d8
I can't say that this is an easy move to
make though because you know you you
allow Queen H4 maybe bishop G5
she didn't play it she played King E7
King E7 yeah King E7 and now what if I
just take the Knight on C6 well we were
looking at takes and a rook on coming to
B1 that's fine uh good I agree I agree
to take the knights
this position is worrisome I mean your
kings floating around and you know
there's a check
it feels especially in time trouble you
start seeing all kinds of ghosts
and let's just jump to the Juniors as
well because we have some results
expected in the very very near term
we're going to jump to the game of
Mishra for a moment because he's just he
he against Arthur yes this one is over
Rook
look at his tactics this is pretty
H7
it's a touchdown yeah it's a touchdown
exchange and a pawn up after the HDX G7
Mishra knows how to win this position
and that will be all she wrote
but also I just wanted to check in on
Arthur uh goes position because we had
left it with Rook on C3 Rook went back
to C8 Rook to C1 whoa Rook to C1 why did
we play Rook to C1 we were looking more
at Rook takes C7 and Knight G4 and we
really like White's position in that
case because we were eyeballing a check
remember that was a very nice sequence
uh but also before is no longer defended
right I like the Rook on E1 what are we
doing why are we not defending our Pawn
so we munch
again
we Munch and we munch
what are we missing we've got a check
if that's oh wait so do we have to check
an ig4 or an ig4 immediately
maybe we have Knight G4 immediately
right and even the Knight H6 check looks
very dangerous
okay but uh I mean I have to say these
are says mixed shifts happening and the
Juniors
sizing shifts okay uh we don't have one
trade we do already have an a rook trade
and it's
at the time of the clock effector in
this one yet so both have around nine
minutes four how many moons four six
more moves okay nothing really dangerous
but I have to say our tournament leader
is definitely being put under pressure
by adjacent Mishra winning
how's Brandon doing we left it Justin
and Brandon were more or less balanced
and Justin enjoying an extra Pawn maybe
only temporarily and yeah very quick
movement looks like a draw is inevitable
in that one and Christian I'm going to
turn it over to you as we have guests in
studio Rue Yang another victory for you
and now you're in second place uh
congratulations that must feel pretty
good you've been laboring quite hard to
get to where you are right now yeah I
mean I haven't like really I've just
been like relaxing before the game like
I haven't like done any pressure
basically and it worked today I have to
say and take us through the game tell us
I think like about the moment the
critical moment I think so Queenie two
like after Knight B7 I feel like she
probably could have like improved like
Queen maybe like Queen F6 I thought but
like I feel like she played like a
little oh too slow and like allow me to
get like C4 and I see theory in and she
didn't really really have like a king
side attack and now you're pressuring
everything on the queen side
and then slowly slowly yeah
very nice travel and transfer the Knight
to C6 Knight D4 another nice uh little
trick to get the exchange
congratulations riyanka definitely
feeling good you cannot win the
tournament uh at this point but you're
still fighting for a second position is
that the goal and how are you going to
approach tomorrow's game well I'm trying
to think about it too much because I
feel like it's just gonna stress me out
even more so I'm just gonna like play
like you know normally play what I
usually play and just hopefully win the
last round well Ryan you're definitely
on the right track you've been showing
great chess in the last few rounds we'll
see you tomorrow
our congratulations as well and we have
also a result that amazing games
that was uh is some back and forth going
on there at one moment we really thought
that Kirk had really misplate it was in
great trouble he was fighting his way
back in the game right here that was
that great move Queen E8 uh and it was
followed up with this very nice
monstrous move actually Rook takes D5
and from here
um well he went on to win as
well I'll eventually get there the it
was the sea part after all right the
bishop on A3 Landing again
yes and uh C Pond uh promoting uh for
those who are joining us late are
congratulations to malikset who has won
the senior championships with one game
to go absolutely fantastic
and Alice Lee uh Drew her game so she's
in a position that if Zoe
doesn't win right Zoe has his dad game
got a bit complicated but that was the
night B2 I was so happy but then a lot
Queen trades what happened we can still
make a draw and still it will be decided
tomorrow because she will be one point
behind only if she makes a draw so
there's still that opportunity for
tiebre so somehow they got the position
that we wanted her to get take Stakes
before
but this is like we we thought well this
is very nice
place to be five maybe there is a
problem with that but I thought I'm just
gonna stop any kind of counter play
White can have exactly figure out what I
want to do and press uh as always
against the okay I'm I'm forced treat
trade Queens okay and uh seizing her
opportunity with Zoe to get out of this
monstrous pin and where we could have
gotten into a bishop ending that
I don't know somehow this feels like Zoe
is kind of getting some chances right to
save the game yeah to save the game to
save the game not the win of course
exactly
yeah but starting from that opening
where it was terrible terrible just
maybe even lose that H3 move that was uh
really uh bad sorry uh the Rochelle game
which is you know chaos right I just I
just think it's something you just have
to look at because it's kind of Bizarro
world queen takes C6 on the board Rook
B1
clock times once again yeah so Kelsey
has one minute five seconds and yeah
Russia has seven minutes and she has a
big big move right now if she finds it
she's actually better King D1 no Bishop
D1
Bishop D1 because you want to play
rookie too and I also yeah okay this is
not easy not easy stuff
wow Bishop D1
Bishop I were activating that Rook from
A2 really difficult once you see Bishop
D1 it makes sense right find that move
well Bishop D1 check this out because
you kind of you you uh walk the king
back to the king size right into a
meeting net you say now come over here
come a little bit closer let me
introduce you to my Rook I would like to
uh and the rook and see one is hanging
so just average the benefits at the end
of the line but through the trouble Rook
be Bishop D if she see if she finds she
found it she played it Bishop
Bishop D1 is on the board
cold shower my goodness incredible
okay I mean when you play Rook A2 you in
your your dream land and your great
great fantasy The Rook comes to check
you on the E5 yeah who wouldn't imagine
on move 12th I don't move 29. finally
you actually moved the Rook again that
was the dream Bishop D1 okay
the game with black like how Bishop C8
right yes you have to go Bishop C8
Bishop C8 try to match but now I can
play Bishop G5 also I don't know if I
want to do it right now but that Bishop
is free to go no longer paint right it's
no longer pin oh my goodness so I'm
forced to play 15 seconds for Kelsey
right now because he has to make a move
and that's a shock just I mean the shock
of seeing rookie to appear five seconds
five seconds and Rook to D6 what did she
do I'm gonna refresh my board everybody
The Rook D6 okay so she's ready to meet
rookie two with Rook E6
but can I start first with Queen C7
there's 94 there's bit your queen C7 oh
but you've got to bring come on remember
when you're gonna throw a party
make sure all friends are attending yes
send out invitations Rook E2 check okay
six would probably be forced yes now
it's time right Bishop check
or is it time to play night to do no
that allows it a chat yeah it sounds
like yeah 94 is a bit too slow okay
um do we actually have to give this
track I'm telling you I think I'm a
bigger fan of maybe Queen C7 Queen why
don't we start with Bishop G5 though
Bishop G5 Bishop G5
isn't that forcing us
is making that move Bishop G5 on the
board to Rochelle's hand
11 moves with 30 seconds to go for
Kelsey oh the outrook G7 I mean come on
you come on sometimes you got a bluff
Kate I'm telling you you know good chess
yes I'm all for a good chess but
sometimes you just gotta throw it out
there and hope for the best F6 with
seven seconds on the clock oh oh okay
now
now is the time will somebody please
tell me it's time to invite my Rook into
uh the game rookie two I think I agree
with you no finally I've got a that's a
bit of support no no no no come on come
on you're not allowed to agree with yes
wow wow
wow
wow it's tough I
like Rodney Dangerfield there yeah
tough crowd tough crowd okay what do we
got rookie two rookie six I don't okay
we're looking for a really the maid
right okay let's keep going rokitu yes a
nice follow okay so let's try it okay
rookie two rookie six Queen C7 sorry
kind of taking a page from your your
booklet the only move King E8 right
otherwise Bishop eight six I don't know
yeah you're kind of like helping me so
King E8 but King E8 still still kicking
right good so can I go Queens
six well then I go back right
all I've got is a Perpetual I'm coming
out empty-handed no that's shocking I
cannot believe that that's shocking okay
okay how about the symbol please
oh sorry Rook E6 Rook E2 rookies rookie
the rookie six sorry okay
simple chess all about does the simple
King have to make any sense King F2
well but now I capture the bishop and
I'm guarding the force Cliff yes I'm I'm
still not doing anything with with that
we're all excited and suddenly The
Crickets and we have to be careful about
let's say I thought move Knight D4 to
like attack the key the queen and
prepare Rook E2 but then black can have
a counter attack right Rook takes D1
with check and queen B1 hello
on the board rookie two very logical
move rookie seven immediate follow-up
she needs a follow-up yeah this is the
crucial moment right here right now
after this move rookie six what's our
what's our genius plan
don't tell me it's taking the bishop
I'll go grab this one with both hands uh
I will grab the bishop and be eyeballing
Queen D3 sorry uh Kate
what do you reckon Rochelle's got to do
I mean maybe sometimes you know you just
gotta accept the draw Jack and Jack I
mean that's a still you know a great
result for Rochelle because that yeah
she was busted she was best right but I
still feel like there should be
something all right let's go Queen C7
okay
um
okay I don't see anything I don't either
maybe bishop G5 was not the correct way
right
well I mean the whole beautiful part
about the move Bishop D1 was to be able
to to break the pin and yep we're seeing
the Perpetual Queen C7 group King eight
sorry I I apologize I'm just going to
refresh my board for just a moment and
we do have Queen C1 King this Rook takes
D1 is a very serious threat right and
whenever you don't give me a check I'm
just gonna capture that Bishop
I'm sorry I was thinking about it about
an incident that had happened with
Maurice Ashley and I uh I mean the
pyrotechnics of Rook G7 and F6 and queen
here and everything
um
Maurice and I had gone to the St Louis
University Billikens basketball game and
one of the players had taken an in
between the legs dribble and we stepped
back for a three-pointer not only did he
miss the basket I mean he hit the
cheerleading section and it was crickets
crickets
hurt ourselves laughing we were laughing
so all the pyrotechnics aside it might
just be a Perpetual yeah I mean
the unfortunate part here is Rochelle
saves the game but nothing more I mean
can you just show the move 24 Rook days
G7
oh we have a result
we kind of lost uh track of the so
Andrew honk winning with Josiah
stillerman right
he could be tied for the leads
for lead because I'll be Mario is
winning this game right but still very
important win for Andrew to stay in the
hunt yes
and Mishra is putting the final touches
on his game as his campaign to win the
uh
junior Championship is in full swing
he's just not working days
this is absolutely
six King takes the six sacrifice The
Exchange sacrifice
sacrifice I don't capture all the black
bombs it's a nice sacrifice a nice
sacrifice and here we see a real thing
stunning very nice transposition to a
winning pawn and game okay
56 and suddenly you know it's it's
really funny also how
the scoresheet writing improves once you
know with the absolute 100 certitude
that you're winning
and that game is over our
congratulations to Mishra as he's now
looking anxiously towards the Jason uh
Liang versus Arthur Gil position and by
the way we left it at Rook takes C3
Arthur didn't want to go for the Palm he
just felt that that was too dangerous to
try to collect upon Rook takes Queen
takes Knight G4 but he did his job I
mean abhimanyu did his job yes he did
right that's
he had to win this one with the white
pieces there was no other result
acceptable for him exactly by the way I
I liked uh up to this moment what Jason
had done if he had gone into that
variation that we'd talked about before
you just start playing against the night
and you start playing against the pawns
you play a move like rookie one and then
you start looking at moves like Queen A6
it really looks like it's a two result
game you know well Black's pawns uh weak
pawns on B5 D6 F4 he played uh instead
the move King rookie won Queen F6 and uh
well Arthur still in trouble still in
trouble but maybe uh better chances of
holding but we have a guest in studio uh
Christian over to you Balaji another
important victory for you against a very
tough opponent with the black pieces and
it all started early on in the opening
did you know about this E5 trap yeah I
mean I I saw this before hand and
because if C4 works okay it's not I
don't like the position too much for
Block then you're in trouble yeah but E5
is a very important move and already it
gets really difficult for him to play I
think absolutely and but he was still
holding on and he was making some really
testing moves especially at this point
it felt like you're finally putting in
the finishing touches beautiful move
Queen to A4 nice transition and then
panic mode hit for him he has to do
something he cannot exchange on A4
but at this point you had this move
Bishop to D5 did you see I did but what
happened was I saw Bishop F5 and I
thought this should be an easier way and
just hitting B1 and like I saw G5 Bishop
G6 and I thought that should be
basically game over but I definitely
completely underestimated how his
counter play came and you missed this
queen yeah Queen three right yeah yeah
this is a very hidden move to see how
far right
Queen to A6 and now things are getting
yeah the spice yeah I think D5 Queen E8
and I thought D6 here was very testing
and I couldn't but he managed to kept
your composure Because by the way if you
don't go Queen to E8 which is the best
move right now then he equalizes it
almost
so he played Queen E8
and finally got the Rook D5 in at which
point were you certain that finally you
put the right finishing touches I think
as soon as you played Rook D2 first of
all Rook D2 just seemed very suspicious
to me because you're walking right into
my Bishop's like View and so Rotex D5 is
like one of the first things to
calculate in that line and as soon as I
saw there's no attack on my king and
lion we played in the game and C3 C2
just comes perfect timed I thought so as
soon as slc3 I knew I was winning I
think there
well Balaji an important victory for you
congratulations you right now I believe
half a point behind the leader going
into the final one yeah I'll tell us
about the strategy for that final round
well of course I'm gonna try to win
tomorrow but it's not gonna be easy at
all I'm playing Mishra and so it's I'll
try my best and whatever happens happens
I'm already happy with the way I managed
to recover and so I'll just try to
finish how I can white pieces against uh
one of the leaders maybe the co-leader
going into the final round that's the
best scenario you could ask for
congratulations we'll actually we'll see
you tomorrow thank you
have you played against Mishra in the
past is this your going to be your first
meeting
I think we faced quite maybe face like
seven or eight times already was my
question
yeah how do you do
so far I actually have pretty good score
I think I'm something like plus three
against him
okay all of them are really fighting
games so I wouldn't say it's been like a
one-sided okay but uh definitely you
know each other well good luck tomorrow
thank you absolutely as uh we uh still
looking at the Carissa yet versus uh Zoe
Tang game uh Zoe
yeah that's what I'm saying thinking
I've got checks but uh for Zoe if she
doesn't win once again just to remind
everybody she's a trailing Alice coming
in today by a full point so she can't
lose that's the whole point right away
exactly we have a second champion
and by the way uh during our interview
break there we Rochelle
versus Kelsey that was like a draw I
made all the excitement that crazy game
that that we were thrilled about there
was nothing at the end of the there but
but it was this there was I mean there
was yes yes look good for Kelsey for
keeping her composure after that Bishop
to D1 because Rook to D6 is probably the
best move at that moment that and she
had no time when she found them she made
it with like seven seconds or something
like that uh but you're saying that
Rochelle missed something after Rook D6
yes you have the move Queen to C5
just chill the idea being that I'm
pinning your Rook so that whenever you
uh take on C1 and I give you a check you
cannot cover with the rook and if we
have to move the king probably 95 then
we've got 95. so Queen C5 was the key
move and and by the way it doesn't
finish there right 95 of Queen E5 rookie
5 C2 I'm still not convinced that this
is exactly the way to go some wild stuff
maybe we have Queen takes A7 maybe
before yes
I don't like 95 too much
crazy can we go first queen A7
absolutely wild stuff yeah I mean good
luck calculating this with uh a week to
analyze something along those I mean
calculus surviving this with like 30
seconds on the clock always playing with
five seconds left yeah very beautiful
day
fun fun stuff I mean so many any
decisive games in the round just
checking out the junior section once
more I wanted to say that yeah there
were all decisive games we have three
results three wins and Jason Liang
Arthur still playing Justin and Brandon
we do think that Justin Wang and Brandon
Jacobson will be a draw but uh yeah the
junior players have been really
decisive Games Galore and finally I just
wanted to see the senior section because
we we saw that incredible game
of uh
Doug Root versus Gregory guidanov Adina
if you joined us late shame on you but
it was a Danish Gambit two two Pawn
sacrifice Doug
played a beautiful game very nice last
tactics really nice attached to the
whole beautiful Masterpiece and
explained that he had been with his
Collegiate team analyzing his opening
day and night and a college chess man a
Christian I gotta tell you it's some
good stuff you should know what's going
on it's definitely uh developing in the
right direction that's for sure College
trust is getting better and better we do
have Kelsey with us Kelsey an absolutely
crazy wild game this was we had no idea
what was happening we had the engine to
help us but still couldn't understand
much tell us a bit about your experience
with this game well so in the opening
um when she put the nimso she normally
doesn't play after so I prepare for
I played
c5b5 and I wasn't expecting E5 so here
like I was thinking a lot I was thinking
the normal for just to be Retreat to E8
but then I was thinking maybe it would
be too passive like
um she might pick up B5 and then develop
normally yeah so I wanted to go for
something like you might as well go for
it right why not
let's go for it nothing to lose Bishop
A5 and she was by the way blitzing out
her moves like she knew uh what she was
doing were you afraid of her
collaboration yours here at this point
but still you're finding the best moves
and take on C4 and at this point she
started thinking a little bit she had an
hour and 33 minutes then F4 was played
after a 10 minute thing how did you
assess the position at this point also I
was really puzzled because I was
thinking there's no way this could work
for her or for me though because like my
pawns they look so ugly but if I can get
a D5 before in yeah um it seems pretty
good for me but she has like no
development so I was really puzzled at
this point yeah no and I think F4 was in
fact quite a big blunder and you jumped
on the opportunity you found the right
plan just get that Rook on the B1 create
those pins and then start pushing the
pawns yeah now at this point it became
desperation mode yeah I think like last
Stitch efforts are the most scary
because like
have anything to lose and then I saw she
would get a ton of counter play and then
I got really scared because like I had
no time either you were going down to
your last few minutes at this point
and I think this was the critical moment
you could have played Queen to G6 but
you had one minute on the clock what was
going on through your mind so I was
thinking if I play Queen G6 um that's
what I was originally intending to play
yeah then I was thinking what if my king
gets cut off like somehow quinnish
during and Bishop G5 I can always
Retreat to G7 but so I think this was
the move where
um I got down to like 30 seconds yes for
the first time yes and then so I just
had to play a move and then I played
this one which you know 23 seconds and I
have to say you really kept your
composure after this move Bishop to D1
because this is almost like a cold
shower type of situation right I wasn't
understanding at all like I was either
thinking King D1 or um
something else because here I have
Bishop B5 and Bishop A4 precisely yeah
and this would have led to a victory uh
but she found this great move Bishop to
D1 and then you also counteracted with
this great move to this is from a
practical perspective I think the best
movie in the position
did you see this move Queen to C5
for her or
I didn't consider anything other than
checks because I thought that would be
too slow for some reason yes and that's
what she went for as well and finally
this absolutely Wild game finished in a
Perpetual how would you sum up your
experience here at the junior girls
um I guess I shouldn't be disappointed
since it's my first time and I I didn't
lose too badly
um but I feel like definitely in this
game and all my
um
I lost a lot of games as white which I
wasn't expecting and then this game I
had some good opportunities but
um the tournaments finally almost ending
so yeah Kelsey still you're bringing up
the fighting Spirit to every single game
congratulations and we'll see you
tomorrow in the Final Round Guys any
questions absolutely yeah Kelsey first
of all congratulations what a
game I mean incredible incredible game
we were really enjoying it all those
pawns pushing uh my question is you are
super young you're only 14 years old
national Master really accomplished
chess player uh how are you enjoying
this tournament playing the best girls
like carissaib I mean really strong
tournament tournament is this your first
time playing this yeah of course it's my
first time and I always wanted to play
it since a really long time since I just
watched the broadcasts online and then
for this tournament I guess I just want
to play some more good games
um probably good before exciting but
yeah
I just wanted to say thank you Kelsey uh
you thrilled us and you forced the
commentators to put us on our toes so it
was a great game thrilling game thank
you thank you absolutely good luck
tomorrow wow last round love it
well it's not often we have a situation
like that Rook on a rook sacrifice and
the Kings running across the board and
with no time on the clock and then like
so like Rook days G7 right some precise
game from from Rochelle with Bishop D1
but still with black surviving that Rook
D6 wow and if Rochelle would have found
Queen C5 that's like okay that's alien
stuff uh again I'm just gonna check in
on Zoe and Carissa as we get prepared
for a break
Zoe well she's she's hanging in there
but she's a pawn down and uh yeah she's
attacking that A5 Pawn right yeah she's
keeping the bishop honest and The Rook
is actually active kind of tying down
Black's pieces a little bit uh you you
would like to go King to C7 and uh evict
The Rook the problem is F Pawn so maybe
a move like H5 here for Carissa by the
way uh the players have made their time
control everybody's happy there we have
one another game going on in the girl
section Rose and Gracie for for the
longest time I've been liking white but
it's kind of hard with this I want to
say
passive Bishop the bishop is you would
love to trade off this bishop so you
could just land on the F5 Square it's
not easy for Rose to improve what I
thought was a very good position but I
think that could be an interesting plan
right maybe bishop E2 Bishop G4 just try
to trade off those pieces
makes sense to me very very well and uh
Christian back to you as we're guest in
studio we are with the current leader of
the Junior's section ABI Manu first of
all congratulations you came into this
round as the rating favorite you are
playing against a struggling player and
you did your job you did exactly what
you were supposed to do how are you
feeling right now as a new leader at
least until the last few games are over
yeah it feels feels good I definitely
missed a lot of chances in this
tournament I've been lucky as well a lot
of times like for example my game is
Josiah was like dead lost then yesterday
I missed Bishop C7 like Bishop C7 is
something I would find in the Blitz game
right I completely forgot I missed the
moment I was completely focused on
fixated on attacking on the king side
like forcing G6 to go H4 H5 but yeah
other than that Bishop C7 that game was
not too bad so yeah I had a lot of time
yesterday because he doesn't have what
are you upset about that Miss Bishop to
C7 because sometimes you know you make
this type of draws you see that you have
the clear win and then you beat yourself
a bit too much do you do that yeah it
was of course I was very very angry at
myself okay how could I miss such a
thing because especially that after
every single one of my games where like
if I made any mistakes I'll set up the
same position on the board I'll try to
find the better move like I found Bishop
C7 within like three minutes yeah like
two three minutes it was very simple is
your dad helping you with that do you
see yeah the positions
during the game he puts it on our engine
and okay by the time I come out there's
like a list of lists of things
really okay because I think yeah if
it'll help me more than just like
checking oh this is what I missed okay
now the next game it'll be kind of it'll
be simpler for me to find those kind of
resources is it the me you do that
immediately after the games when you go
back to the room and then your dad
already has everything set up and yes
incredible yeah I mean I don't know what
to say to that that's uh dedication I
want to say and today you spotted the
moment the training has definitely paid
off because at this point you had this
G4 G5 but it wasn't clear I mean we were
looking at the engine the engine was
saying plus two plus three doesn't
really matter right the position is
still equal in terms of material and if
you don't find this G5 G4 G5 it's not
that clear either right yeah they should
come up to the conclusion of that that
is the decisive way
because here once I got this G4 G I
think this mean the whole position is
about my my Bishop on D5
and his idea with Rook FDA is somewhere
he wants to go 97 like I think instead
of look after it you can still go 97
directly maybe what he forgot was that
like At first if I was considering
Knight takes E5 but I realized okay you
can play D Tech C5 and he kind of gets
the he kind of just takes on D5 yeah and
this is completely fine but 97 ideas I
would go back Bishop E3
so you know Bishop B3 I'm never going to
give up this bishop without the light
Square Bishop yeah
so now my thread is actually now G4 G5
is a big threat
there were some interesting moments
before this like when I uh I wanted to
sack my queen with like Knight takes E5
at some points it doesn't really work
okay so okay like with the queen on d8
for example uh where was it maybe
somewhere around here yeah like some
around here like if I I was going to I
was calculating Knight takes E5
like okay Bishop takes D1 Knight takes
c66 is winning for whites
yes I take another piece only some of
the checks and I take on D1 and I have
like the best three pieces that anyone
could imagine absolutely but the issue
with this is Knight takes E5 I think he
can play a knight takes C5
Knight takes up six takes Queen takes H5
Knight takes D3 Rook E3 now the
variation doesn't end because if Knight
takes V2 Rook H3 I give mate
so but the issue is rookie three he goes
to G6 now if I go Queen H6 Bishop G7 my
queen gets forced back because then he
takes on B2 yeah Bishop D5 is also also
an issue I think this one yeah terrible
yeah crazy calculation but you did find
this G4 G5 and in fact after this uh the
position is almost hopeless actually
there was one more Point like uh after
Knight H4 Bishop
and a couple moves after H4 H5 this is a
critical moment to
because here like the first I would I
would have played like rookie six in a
couple seconds but then I've noticed
this GTX H6 and queen G2 because Rook A6
this position is much much better
probably even still winning because I
have this amazing Bishop on D5 you can
you could it's positionally you cannot
exchange it you cannot transfer this
bishop to E6 yeah unfortunately that's
not how chess but then I realized
actually I go GTX H6 now this if Queen
takes H4 Queen G2 and like in the game I
just have way too many threads because
Queen H5 hook E3 is game over because
Queen H6 Rook H3 and queen takes G6
but another variation was GTX H6
and that this is the reason I spent like
10 minutes around here because now H5
Bishop H7 King F1 is the most natural
move uh Bishop Bishop G7
King E2
now Rook of it
now the idea of black setup is okay King
in F5 if you get King h8 F5 you might
still be worth but
maybe you can yeah Rook G1 yes uh King
h8 and it I don't think it was take my
idea was Rook A7 here Rook eight whoa
well Bishop H6 and then okay seven
because actually yeah book A7 and these
were the two most I was calculated
that's actually quite uh beautiful and
now okay Queen H4 I have Rook G4 if you
take it
D7 Queen H4 and book G4
oh that's nice and other than that
actually instead of this I was
calculating the reverse order if I go
Rook A7 first
yes uh Queen takes A7
Bishop takes H6 I think here Black Goes
F5
Bishop takes G7 Queen takes G7 Rook
takes G7 King takes G7
now if I go Queen G3 King H6 I might
still be winning but it's not as clear
and if I go Queen E3 F4 maybe like most
probably white still has a win here but
Queen is not clear but yeah I think
Bishop H6 first is very important 700
signs nice critical moment you spotted
that one you figured everything out I'll
be money congratulations you did what
you had to do you're going in the final
round big game tomorrow against bolaji
who is absolutely on fire how are you
going to approach that one are you going
to play a defensive game or or you don't
want to reveal your strategy well it's
going to be a fight tomorrow because I
think as you know like it depends
whatever happens in Arthur's game I
think he was probably going to make a
draw last I've checked I'm not entirely
sure
but yeah it's but still it has some work
to be done that's awesome position with
Queens on the board but yeah this this
looks kind of dangerous for black but
yeah that meantime at least like share
it first yeah I'll just I'll play I'll
play my best and we'll see what happens
no compromise guys questions for abhiman
our congratulations very very nice
variations that you're calculating the
Mishra and very good luck for tomorrow's
uh all-important game right I have maybe
just one question I'll remind you do you
uh tomorrow very important game do you
think you're gonna have you know issues
falling asleep or because those nerves
are gonna be you know playing out or you
are just it's gonna be easy I'm gonna
fall asleep play out play game tomorrow
but yeah actually as of now yeah this is
a great question but as of now me
worrying isn't going to change anything
what I should best do is like run I
should go to sleep as quickly as
possible then I should prepare normally
but yeah this I I'm going to try not to
think so much about it because whatever
happens on the board will happen
worrying beforehand it will not change
anything
very good are you sure very good good
luck and take us through our results uh
as they're uh piling up uh hot and
furiously for results right so let's
start with the U.S general Championship
Wang Drew with Jacobson hunk won against
steermen very important win Liang is
still playing with Google huge huge game
as our tournament leader leader Arthur
yo is trying to save it lost to dagupati
and Mishra won with Sue and what about
the girls in the girls section
so far we have only two results wow it
was that Rochelle game that really boy
that was amazing sorry those are
fighting so Yen against mangalam Yen won
against mangalam Lee Drew with Mo and I
believe
true with Liu
yeah yes all right and the oh well we'll
we'll talk we'll come to the seniors as
well but first we have a guest in studio
with Christian over to you Andrew on
absolutely Wild game but it was all
about Josiah's early on pressure due to
his opening preparation I mean you had
to make some difficult decisions along
the way what was your first reaction
after this move F6 because black can
play E6 G6 you've played against those
but not against F6 take us through your
reaction
um when he played F6 I recalled vaguely
that this move is maybe possible but um
it shouldn't be great but obviously had
I had to start thinking from what's this
move seven so
um I'll just try to play
um you know what seemed logical to me
but you know I was prepared that you
know he probably looked at stuff so I'd
have to continue playing Under Pressure
which isn't which isn't fun but um and
that's exactly what happened right and
at this point you had the opportunity to
repeat the position yeah right and then
go with Bishop to D4 Rook to B8 you
could still go Bishop to A7 and that
would have ended the game but that
doesn't help you in the standings right
you're still playing for the national
title how did you come to the conclusion
that down an hour on the clock you have
to find something well actually the
decision was like less about the
standings in the tournament I was just
like
a bit and I've been quite upset if I had
to just make a draw with white
um where he had been basically didn't
have to do anything so I felt like okay
I'm you know I might as well just
go for it go for it and see what happens
and there's a lot going on here I have a
lot of options on G3 rookie one Knight
takes C6 a lot to calculate but um yeah
all of them wasn't so clear to me
um for instance like one line here
rookie one looks very natural but
um just here after B5 it's the position
this I wasn't completely sure about
um
why it gets like two pieces I mean two
pawns for two pieces but but for rookie
one actually the bigger issues I
calculated Bishop D6 he has so I take on
C6 now the idea is that he cannot take
back because with the pawn because
Bishop 695 with the double pin
[Music]
um
that's the point very nice but uh but
after Bishop D6 he has I think Bishop
takes Knight Bishop F4 check King B1
Queen C6 I saw Bishop A7 here
um Bishop Bishop A7 the double throw on
the rook in the bishop but here I
thought black at least can take on A4
Knight takes Rook 8 Knight B6 yeah Rook
A7 Rook Knight C8 Rook a knight B6 rook
d8 and black is definitely not worse
here so I thought I I can't go for this
a lot of stuff yeah
so I calculate a lot but none of them
seem so satisfactory to me so I just
took on C6 and played Bishop E5 and was
like okay I might I don't think I have
anything here but I might as well just
play yeah this is you know tame the
position a little bit make sure you're
not getting checkmated you're not losing
any pieces and just play the game as it
is make natural moves right put the
hooks on the open files and it was this
moment I mean you played F5 with only
six minutes on the clock and he found
some really good moves yeah but it was
at this point after C4 where he got
greedy with his move Queen to F6 yeah I
mean
I I totally understand his logic um I
had like no time on my clock he had over
an hour yes and my king is so weak um
but yeah this move looks very tempting
but I've seen that I had at least rookie
three here did you see this from afar
yeah or calculating this and I was
hoping you would go into this I wasn't
completely sure that maybe I missed
something but
to what I saw I didn't see a clear way
for black to take advantage of this so
when I saw Queen F6 the guy I played
rookie three and um
I have everything under control actually
I I had forgotten this move Rook before
exists out of time
but luckily I have Queen takes A6 which
is and now the best movie was a bit
crazy it was Queen to d8 yeah did you
even consider this movie or you weren't
looking at in this direction no I wasn't
really looking at that um I thought
about Queen A1 shot that's yeah and
there's a lot going on Queen D4 Rook E1
and I saw C4 Bishop G6 but I'm gonna
take on G6 I I thought okay I probably
shouldn't be risking anything but
positions still very complicated so
anything can happen I mean with such a
naked King right yeah but but I thought
to myself that you know at least I get
to make a lot of moves and get closer
time get some time on the clock I might
as well just go for this and this was
the big mistake after Queen to G5
already things are turning your way uh
quite clearly because you have this idea
with Queen to age for exchange the
queens and this is an easy end game huge
important victory for you Andrew
tomorrow only half a point most likely
behind the leader going into the final
one who are you playing tomorrow oh I'm
playing
oh that's a big matchup big head to head
what is your uh General experience with
um who is one of your good friends yeah
it's one of my good friends I know
generally
um I do well against him for whatever
reason but uh you know that doesn't mean
anything for tomorrow's game and
you know I'll just you know do my best
and
I mean to be in this position uh
considering what I did yesterday this is
a little bit a little bit of improvement
so I'll take it absolutely Andrew
congratulations we'll see you tomorrow
thank you our congratulations as well
Andrew as well we've yeah it's been a
great round just what we'd expect in a
championship round but let's uh check
out the seniors results uh Kate to be
honors no we have three games that
already finished Korea which Drew with
shabalov Katie Andrew with wolf and Ruth
won against kaidanov we think Benjamin
and acopian are heading for the well
delugie might be in some trouble but
guess what we have a winner we do
singers Championship congratulations to
Grandmaster Malik satkachin with a
fantastic performance in this tournament
and he is the 2023 us senior champion
and with that title comes twenty
thousand dollars congratulations Malik
absolutely well done indeed and we'll
take a break and we'll be right back
[Music]
I'm quite honored to be here and uh
it reminds me of my days when I played
in the U.S junior clubs
feels great it feels great this is my
main Tournament of the year as soon as
the last one is over I start thinking
about the next year it's a great feeling
all this
I'm waiting to come to St Louis because
probably it's
the best conditions for the tournament
it's in Saint Louis it was a great
experience last year as well the first
time I played here as always it's great
so I I'm sure that this time
will be the same
I would like to thank everybody who made
this tournament possible and especially
of course Eric singfield it's great but
it's also nerve-wracking because this is
the most important Tournament of the
Year for me and I really want to do well
so you know I'm I'm gonna try to to
Really Work Hard actually I think I put
more work into it before because I don't
want to be to be too exhausted during
the event but I'm really looking forward
to the games of course I'm very excited
it's very excited just to be here to
qualify it I was very excited to get to
be a senior open last year it was really
really successful for me so I'm very
happy to be back in Saint Louis for a
long time it's uh became a second home
so just back home again it's honor
always honored to be here I think it's a
dream for every chess player to be here
because I always be saying that for
years no one no one else no Organization
no facilities no one else three chess
players as high as here
and we are appreciate it and this is
amazing that's why for us every time if
there is a chance for us to qualify and
play Instant lawyers that dream come
true this is the my the one big turn of
the year they play in
um and so I look forward to actually
remembering how to play chess it's uh
it's wonderful to be here it's amazing
that you know the price fund is the
first place I think is more than the
total price fund of the world senior
championship for example so it's kind of
amazing you know
so I mean I think it's it's a kudos to
Rex and then maybe Fida should work on
this in themselves uh but uh uh it's
always a joy to see old friends and to
play some good chess and to be you know
treated like royalty here so I enjoy it
a lot
thank you
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in-store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
hello I'm women's current Master William
Tucker jonova I will be doing social
media for the US Juniors and seniors
chess championships follow us in our
social media and get more exciting
behind the scenes action
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen singfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
hello
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
national championships these are our
results Kate yeah for the girls junior
Yen won against mangalan Lee Drew with
Mo and Wu Drew with Liu
in the junior championships in the
journalists we also have four results
all right when Drew with Jacobson hunk
won against tiermann very important win
gazarian lost to the gupati and Mishra
won with zoo and four results also in
the seniors and we do have a champion as
well right so Benjamin Drew with a copy
on gravich Drew with shabalov Katia
Andrew with Patrick Wolf and Ruth won
against kaidanov
and we have our Channel yeah these
results means Grandmaster Medics have
catch in is the new 2023 U.S Senior
Champion congratulations what a
fantastic performance in this tournament
and he is also winning 20 dollars twenty
thousand dollars nice sleeper twenty
thousand dollars uh richer and happier
very nice and we've got two very uh
crucial games going on as Arthur
who came into the round as our
tournament leader he's struggling to
hang on to his tournament lead as uh
White Jason mayang is targeting Black's
Pawn structure in this current position
we also have uh Carissa and Zoe at
another crucial game going on in the
girls sections if Zoe can hang on in a
difficult position very difficult
position but now she's a pawn down right
but if you survive then she keep we
Alice Lee will not have clinched quite
yet even so he think loses this game we
do have a winner in the U.S juniors
girls units Championship with Alice Lee
just fantastic performance absolutely
absolutely and Christian what is caught
your attention about these games uh in
progress while I was just checking this
game of Jason versus arthuram yes we're
trying to figure out how to assess this
position after Knight takes F4 right of
course that's a big question what if I
take another opponent then I'm ready 98
right 98 that's the big one and then I
have Rook Cafe
wow that's the nice way out but how do
we first of all I think after Knight to
D6 I'm going to go I'm not going to go
before immediately because of Knight to
C6 right how do we assess this one is
the B Pawn enough
to uh keep my night away and potentially
uh stop my Pawn push on the king side
forcing a draw let's take a look Knight
takes F4 and Jason is actually asking
those questions in 98.98 is on the board
so here it comes Rook f8 he has to go
for it yes right at this point you kind
of you're only I mean you can go Rook at
five and then go Rook F6 and make a drop
right but you don't want that right no
oh perhaps also Rook F5 and then once
you go no but 96
96 root D5 how do we think about that
position
uh once one more time 98 Rook F5 but now
you go Knight G7 right now yes if you go
I get a check all right and I'm happy
but Knight to G7 uh forces the
repetition yes and then eventually to
avoid the repetition I have to go Rook a
thing and Christian has this alien
question Kate uh your initial reaction
when you saw this Knight ending was to
think what that fade on here we go that
this outside pass Pawn you're you're
unite is going to be required to to keep
and then yes against one on the king
side and that
makes me quite comfortable that's why so
the Knight will keep an eye on that pawn
but the king and the pawns will just run
uh overwhite yes but I mean I I think
this might be enough for equality for
Toronto for a black that's what I was
thinking too that the idea that this
Knight is you know Tethered to uh the
queen side right I mean
then eventually you it it's going to be
we think two versus none right yes but
uh I'll play B4 and then the Knight will
be stuck just don't go B4 right now
no
um my initial reaction was it's likely a
draw actually and I think you're right
yeah
I think you are right is it a table base
by the way
no no no no no no I I think we're far
away reduce material though right what
do we got one two we have eight pieces
right
five six seven eight
sorry nine pieces yes that's too many I
think yes perhaps seven pieces is a
table base I don't think we have eight
pieces yet yeah we have to wait for a
pair of ponds or yeah to be traded right
can we turn listen to the seniors last
game playing Maxim Globe against Igor
novikov uh when I left it I thought Igor
was winning but I I mean black is trying
to just put push G2 yes yes he is he's
G2 and Rook takes uh D4 is on his agenda
I'm gonna have to play Rook G6 whether I
like it or not right but then I have F4
I know oh but maybe eight no age seven
may I have a look uh whose turn is it it
is yes
so a four F4 it's my Rook
H7
now unless there's some beautiful mating
check mating sequence
oh there is a really nice I'm just
hearing from uh Grandmaster Darius he's
saying Bishop F3 after eight seven uh f
H7 and Bishop F3 very quiet move but it
is setting the uh quiet killer is the
what I want to say are we sure this is
game over so Bishop C5 King F7
Rogue F6
oh h8 night no well you have to go King
oh wow so instead of Rook F6 check h8
Knight
[Laughter]
which defends the night what only move
is King here so how do you continue
right now
just trading the Rooks
and the night is in time to eat the the
night there was the night the the minor
piece ending the Night comes from the
grave to save the day that is very funny
crazy it's a crazy line totally
ridiculous absurd and we have f4 on the
board I have foreign
H7 Bishop F3 all right let's try to
figure it out
do we have anything else besides then
Bishop F3
well of course our desire Bishop takes
oops we shouldn't be uh letting our
opponent clean their Pawn we won't have
and you know what the problem is so for
example we can start with Rook D1
and now Bishop to h36
and say that which page five is a mate
h8 Queen protects that square but it's
pretty it is very pretty
um
but what's very very pretty is this uh
now that this Pawn on uh G3 covers the
F2 Square this one covering all of those
squares and so you're set up for this
yeah it is cool Quiet Moves are very
powerful and you look and you think okay
game over
this is crazy so Bishop check
um
if I move my king
then you take away my mating material
and you're crying because I promoted a
queen exactly so you don't move your
cane to D7 you move your king to F7 give
me The Rook threatening the mate tonight
only legal move
and
you have to come to the D file
and I trade it all and the thing is that
you don't actually go Rook to E1
kind of crazy right after King to D7
rookie one doesn't work
because now I go Bishop G2 and F3 oops
and you're not stopping me from going F2
you can decide now so I'm wondering if
we if we actually go back what if I
don't promote into a night and I just
play Bishop D6 Rook D6 immediately
okay so
by the way we have H7 on the board okay
so this is a possibility and Rook D6
right now
good question H2 Maybe
you're not threatening to uh with when
your Bishop was on D4 you were
threatening to promote
D2 that's a very very good answer
it was one of those 50 50s he doesn't
find it
okay uh sorry let me just refresh my
board
and uh
we are here and we're I mean this is
nice you don't take a rook of course not
you don't take a whole Rook you don't
play Rook h 2 to stop the Queen Bishop
have three dead you play Bishops
to set up a checkmating threat if we're
going into that line you did it oh man
that's a nice one that's right on the
board wow you can see Max looking at
you're holding his head oh what okay
what's going on Bishop C5 checks the
only move that's the thing
into that path yes
there's no way out
exactly
I'm wondering what what's going on
through Max Max's head right now because
you know he's been I think he lost three
in a row right he's been on a kind of a
turbulent uh track here like one thing
that
could be his down
swing right now
is the fact that perhaps he thinks he's
already lost
but the good thing is he has 18 minutes
17 minutes 53 seconds to be precise so a
lot of time to find and calculate this
whole variation Bishop C5 and promoting
into a knight
yeah well in in this particular case
again he just doesn't have really much
of a choice he has to play Bishop C5
check
so but he's not happy not happy but
let's go Bishop C5 check by the way
sorry I've got uh we're kind of getting
lost here I wanted to just check in on
the Arthur uh uh Jason Liang Arthur
they've gone into that night ending just
as we've uh prescribed we think it's
enough for Arthur to save the game we'll
keep an eye on that the whole point is
this night we'll have to
stay over here on the queen side whereas
Black's King and Knight will deal with
this three to one majority on the king
side uh finally is Carissa making
progress so she was trying to trap The
Rook if we yeah last move
if I'm allowed to you know play King B8
and King B7 I'm trapping The Rock
exactly that would be nice that would be
nice check is on the board and the whole
point is uh Carissa's Bishop she would
love to play bishop and King but uh her
Bishop is also Tethered to this Pawn so
King B7
and just to refresh everybody's memories
if Carissa does not win
well actually these are just the parents
yeah so tomorrow pairing so Leo against
Atwell Yip playing woo that's gonna be a
big match absolutely uh more against
tank mangalam against Lee Alice can
actually clinch the title if she's gonna
win or even make a draw and then
prasanna against yen
by the way the bearings there are just
incredibly uh remarkable because uh uh
that Cape yeah so Zoo against wank
dagupati against Mishra that's the one I
was thinking about I mean that could
determine the playoff or not then we
have Doug path against Mishra right go
against gazarian Steelman against Liang
and Jacobson against Hong absolutely
everything to be
yeah
and let's uh
uh we are going to jump to the game of
rose and Gracie Grace because something
has gone wrong for white this night on
D4 has become the dominant
uh piece right yeah I I've got a pin on
the second rank that King on H2 may not
be
I've got this a very unpleasant feeling
that Queen E3 could you know hurt would
that be Gracie's first victory
in this tournament wow
because this was a real turnaround
because I thought that Rose was enjoying
Advantage for much of this game if not
in the entirety something went seriously
wrong here for white
yeah because there was this moment when
we wanted to really jump with the knife
there but she actually traded the night
for a bishop and we were thinking Bishop
to G4 you you pointed out that trade
existed for Rose so so black is Queen E3
is that
is it that strong
another one uh just if it was if it was
my turn if I go Queen A2
[Laughter]
uh you're gonna have to go King G1 I
don't know I don't think you're gonna
survive this uh
you don't want to alarm you but okay he
finally made it he finally played Bishop
C5 Maxi Maxim's looking he was taking
his time okay we might see that
promotion perhaps we have to stay with
this one we'll trade uh our I really
want to see that uh game night promotion
yeah it's not often did you see under
promotion and for a night or night yeah
King F7 okay this is the moment right
here
don't pick a queen you're gonna
Checkmate if you have to pick a knight
the Knight is next to Igor you see it
right there it's actually ready yes
right first in line it's like I want to
jump back back to the game
Max is uh hesitating it was is
considering your move Rook to D6 but we
think you have to Rook H2 that's a
problem that's not nice that truly is a
problem the thing is once you
play Under promotion to one night you
have to calculate that variation and you
have to see that at the end of
everything all the exchanges you have
this move Knight to G6 and capture on F4
right that's not that easy right I don't
know in the last hour of play after you
know so much labor so much
effort being put in this if you're not
exhausted you're you're super human and
you cannot stop calculating now only
after Knight G6 wow exactly that's the
thing you sometimes stop calculating and
if you do that then you're in trouble
and by the way
is this completely over let's go King D5
King David five digits right yeah okay
so I'm definitely taking E4
King E4
Okay so
uh
oh no that's how I'm gonna lose G2 now I
go G2 and now I take yeah this is the
way wait actually do I have acid oh
there it is wow nice good job Asics like
I go back I think he found it yeah
I mean you win the game oops yeah
um let me just refresh my board
everybody I'll be right back and here we
go this is it this is the moment rookie
six check and Rook D6 has to go rookie
six
that's a beautiful Stutter Step forcing
the king onto the D file
by the way for Igor
there's some really really really bad
tournaments
luck in this competition I mean he had
Malik said dead to rights yeah yes he
could have easily won that game and
beautiful long Castle right right and
there were other opportunities as well
for Igor where that you know things just
and if this one gets away he's in there
going you know what do I have to do but
sometimes you are missing a little bit
in every single game it's not working
right you're missing a Tempo in one game
your Tempo ahead and you don't want to
be in another just little things
Rook E6 check and Rook D6 with this
Knight on h8
making a fantastic entrance into the
onto the stage
[Laughter]
wow fantastic
it has some study qualities this this
last part yes to it yes no this is like
a study like okay let's keep going with
that end game right that's right
it's kind of forced King D7 maybe maybe
Rook to E1 but I don't think you will
play Rook do you want no if you see this
takes takes night and you are asking the
question here right I just wanted to go
ahead and see if I managed to get that
C3 point in time
so what am I so ig6 maybe to have Knight
D5 okay that makes the most sense so
your immediate King D3 does run into
Knight G6 and I want to use this as a
deal but this is like truly a study-like
position if you go which page five now I
have A6 and I take on G6 and my king
stops me from actually catching your
Pawn right you in this position you want
to capture your king
so that you're so the bishop this is a
study-like position truly crazy and if
you go King now you get to use your Pawn
as a decoy so that you can trade this
when you need to right right like here
here
oops no I've done it in the wrong way I
apologize I'm now go back for a second
go back for a second Maybe
I played Knight E5 this is still not
easy huh
crazy
wow so even
after all of this
Knight H4 right
why is your night better on h4k she
wants to go on F5 I see I see what
you're doing I'm gonna go there
yes I mean when I doing something wrong
and now I think Knight F5 is the move
but
yeah I think
King D3 no I
still like the ship is amazing what a
fantastic yeah but I'm fine right what
no Knight E3
fine
taking Knight takes G2
oh but after 93 you have G1 you just no
91. no but you don't have to push C3
oh sorry what did you want me to do G1
G1 oh Bishop Bishop the underpromotion I
mean if you're gonna under promote I
have to match you okay so this does not
work wow
um Christian 200 promotions in the same
game right I know
that would be a Fantastico
I've never had that by the way I've had
under promotions for sure but not in the
same game that both players are under
promoting what
okay so you have an easy way out I have
an easy way out yes okay we've we didn't
spot this and it's not that easy to
actually Spot It so rookie 6 we have to
play right no we're going keep going all
the way into the end game all the way
until the king reaches the square E4
wow
all right G6
no Knight to G2
not night ah okay because you don't have
King D3 now or kingly three or King D3
Knight to G2
Wow money move okay 96 is supposedly a
dress wall but it's not that easy so I
would say this is the money move that if
you don't see it from afar I mean you
can get tempted
maybe to play something like rookie 6
followed by rookie one and hope that you
save it like this and then I end up in
trouble after Bishop G2 F3 so a lot of
traps still set in the position for uh
loogie in this one well he's definitely
looking at Rook check now his uh
what you're saying is he's trying to
define whether or not he's supposed to
be playing Rook E1 or Rook D6 we think
Rook D6
and let's uh just update our uh stories
here for the seniors once again we want
to congratulate our tournament winner
Kate yes we have Grandmaster Maddox at
cacian who is the 2023 U.S Senior
Champion yeah so congratulations what a
fantastic performance I mean with round
to spirit being a winner that must feel
amazing absolutely undefeated and uh wow
just really really impressive play uh
throughout and then in the junior
section we everything to play for in the
Juniors said okay yeah very important
game between Jason Yang and Arthur Gua
who is so far the leader in the actually
it's not right because
at this moment so but if he wins he
still keeps the lead in the championship
but now he's kind of trying to survive
exactly it's a pawn down and somehow uh
White TR changed the guard the white
King came over to the queen side in
order to release the Knight
from its passive Duty so white is
looking
potentially playing King C5 King tags
that's a double attack I'm attacking G2
and if you push it then H3 is going to
be hanging which kind of provokes me to
play the passive move but okay for the
moment knight uh E1 defends G2 and I'm
still I've got King C5 on my agenda
I don't think you have to be worried
about
let's say I play before before
okay I'm I I want to eliminate the pawn
I wonder if I can go just King E4 with
the idea to capture on G2 right
and then King F3 oops sorry captures on
um G2 and King F3 so if it was your turn
here
you wouldn't capture my my night right
right
so H4 you cap if you capture the Knight
well we know what's gonna happen nothing
good is gonna nothing good but you
capture the pawn but can you take the
other one
King G3
[Music]
that's a draw that's just a dead draw
wow
um night
well what just happened I'm going to
refresh my board everybody don't get
unnervous Knight H4 so that is just
inviting kinji
ah King G5 does he want to invite no you
or maybe he wants to invite King G5 so I
can play King E4
well King g5s on the board
I like these people before because I'm
taking control of that F5 square and I'm
ready to return with my knight and kick
your king kind of fur further further
away yeah I like the I like King E4
that's that's that's a delicate move it
forces the night away because Knight F3
is a killer right so I have to go I'm
gonna check
or do you one oh I maybe have G3 also I
would say yeah yeah yeah
on the board yes I like this
um
okay
uh all-important game here in the
Juniors as our tournament leader Arthur
is really
he if he survives this he's really uh
he's very very very deserving and uh
Jump Right In Christian uh what does
what does the engine say about this
position after King it's it's still
equal but I think 96 is not the best I
have to go Knight E2
not an obvious movement not an obvious
move at all no wow what's the Knight
doing on E2 yeah night night E6 Knight
F3 you start having some difficulties
it's not that straight for Knight to E2
probably is the better way and you know
if black tries to simplify I thought
about this idea and I take H3 but it's
kind of really cool why it doesn't work
Knight takes H3 G takes okay
King takes now play F4 I run black plays
before and now I don't run with the
white Pawn I just push my king and the
blacking is trapped it's trapped you're
eventually forced to take yeah
oh guys I feel we should go to the
delugie game just okay because it's that
critical moment when he has to play Rook
to D6 and he only has three minutes left
on his wow he was 18 minutes I think two
moves that goes I know every movie is
taking a lot of time and now he did play
Rook D6 he just played it oh my goodness
yes he did yes
okay he saved it
I mean he still has to find us that
Knight G2 move right
yes not the only move the most precise
move yes
pretty right to stop and stop King to D3
and
Igor must be thinking to himself you
know what what do I have to do to win a
game around it just is so difficult to
win you can have advantage and just
throughout yeah it's very difficult to
win a game
is that
yes yes Igor has nine minutes Maxim has
formed sorry I do want to turn our
attention also to the game of uh Zoe and
Carissa very important game for the
tournament because again Carissa has
been nursing an extra Pawn for quite
some while and uh for Zoe I mean if she
uh loses this game then it's tournament
victory for Alice Lee
Bishop to T6
can Zoe Play Bishop E5 and take and take
take and take I mean I appreciate that
this uh C Pawn is a runner
so can I go King C5 here well it's uh
White to play and Zoe did Play Bishop E5
and yeah King C5 on the board
and we're anticipating Rook takes
what else oh Bishop takes bishop or
Bishop takes Bishop either one Rook
Bishop takes Rook takes Rook takes F5
check King B4
and if the king were on C2 I know it's a
draw but with the King cut off
I think this is a win for this might be
a win right right
so this is the current position
with Zoe to play and I think her clock
is down
uh another movie's Rook takes a fact but
how good is that oh there's a difference
if I now play King before you don't do
me the favor of taking you give me a
check very strong discoveries yeah
exactly now you're forced to go back and
I can probably trade and that's it wrong
and that's a draw so Rook takes F5
E5 E5
what is that
I'm not sure Oh I thought King D2 but
that's that's actually lost
never mind that should be losing yeah I
have to recapture with the pawn sorry
guys uh just catching up on the current
position the uh
Zoe just played Bishop C3
I kind of like this move
it's a very practical decision right you
just stop thinking you don't want to see
the King on your doorstep supporting uh
the sea pawn and so you have stake on F4
now right yeah right that's what she did
and by the way guys Zoe has only one
minute on the clock exactly oh that's so
she really has to make sure
that is really bad news which is done
by the way
King D4 how why do you play after King
D4
I'm not sure I like the move King D4
because I'm going in yeah so probably
Rook C6 now once again the reminder is
uh that uh if Zoe loses Alice's the uh
2023 girls Champion yes very important
game for Alice I'm sure she's watching
this game
come on Carissa give me do me a favor
you can do it uh King D4 I like that
move let's keep going King D4 Bishop B6
King E4 probably right trying to set uh
sorry yeah there was a piece going to E6
is just the wrong piece and now I'm
setting up rook D2 well oh Rook David
two maybe maybe next oh yeah I know I
like what you did I like what you did
maybe that's the way
by the way just uh uh update uh Gracie
is cruising to Victory and it will be
her first yeah very nice game against
Rose Atwell really kind of crushing it
now on the king side well I mean it's so
nice to play in the National
Championship where you go out with a win
I mean it's uh it's not been a very good
tournament for Gracie but uh winning a
first game
feels good well in fact
breathing-wise she's winning rating
points is she she came in so so low
rated because she's coming into the
event as one of the lower rated players
I see I see and even before this one
she's still winning some rating points
and after this one probably even more
so nice
it's difficult given that you've lost
some games and you haven't won there's a
handshake as Rose
gives it up and she has done it what I
like it is that you know fight till the
end that even if the tournament is not
going your way you are not gonna just
finish with Ross you're still gonna
fight you still will want that win and
here she goes she has her first time I
tell you there's Championship rounds the
last the penultimate as well as the
ultimate round
you win those games and you know
whatever your score was you kind of
leave a little bit happy as this
all-important game Zoe tang and Carissa
Carissa is enjoying a nice time
Advantage but now with the reduced
material
um she still has to find some really
accurate moves I think King bees I like
the move King D4 I really do and maybe
after Bishop B6 maybe I should just keep
going but how worried about maybe A5
exactly that pawn suddenly running it it
certainly is there's no question about
that
um
I'm thinking that I want to trade the F
okay so here let me let me show you what
I'm I'm I mean I'm just going to go a
six
okay I would like a second Christian let
me show okay
okay so Rook goes somewhere where does
The Rook go would you like to go behind
wait you don't want to show what I
missed no
you're on pre unpreet well by the way we
had this conversation yesterday it was
it was a little bit of a shock for a
Christian and I that the international
on pre that we thought was International
was that new for you that on pre wasn't
a part of your uh lexicon and here we go
Bishop Bishop after a long long think
actually well considering the fact she
only has a few minutes she played Bishop
to D6 keeping the tension how does the
engine light them apples Bishop to C3
though right
maybe after that you can force a trade
right Bishop E5 okay and then we're
getting into this rook and pawn you
think this is winning
walking before
well your King's gonna be
wow the engines are saying that the
white somewhat somehow survives but why
this is really not I'll be really
worried about this yeah Rook F7 okay it
is very difficult right now she's losing
right now it's over after King D4 if
Carissa finds it Bishop B6 she played
Rook F7 in now King D4 King D4 now okay
that makes it nice it's time to step in
and that Bishop on D6 is controlling
that Rook so nicely
Bishop B6 I have a feeling you just
simply go King before and then C3 is
coming you're not stopping C3 because
the bishop is guarding E7 C7 all those
really important squares for the Run
that's right King D4 is the money move
for Alice she's like
go Carissa King D4 that's the key move
here huh
oh sorry that was my bad I was just
refresh the board
uh King D4
it's a move that Carousel is most likely
going to make I mean you want to if
you're looking forward it feels very
very natural first of all it doesn't
cover an attack against the bishop and
secondly you want to push your Pawn I
mean pass pawns and all that good stuff
and again what is another move that you
have here for improvement maybe Rook E5
or maybe rookie five
yeah in terms of improvement it's very
hard to match King D4 is it
yeah uh I mean Bishop F4 there's no Rook
D2 so it looks like it's King D4 and
let's go
maybe we can look at maximum
and that is the
by the way did he they went all the way
to that position and guess what an
ig219. he found it I mean my they must
be exhausted and they come up with Nike
too at this moment uh kudos to Max very
very impressive uh indeed Knight E3
check it looks like we can finally use
the a pawn as a decoy to play uh Asics
in order to be able to play nice you can
see how tired they are on their face
the fatigue my goodness what's been
happening in this game look at him
somehow he perked up a little bit when
he found this saving under promotion
right his smiling I can see a smirk on
his face
he's happy he survived this totally
right
but we have a guest in studio with you
Christian over to you Gracie is being a
difficult tournament for EU so far but
finally you got that elusive Victory
tell us about your feelings right now
um I mean I'm just glad that I won a
game and I like found the combination I
guess so I'm just trying to take it one
game at a time and I'm happy that I want
this game tell us about this experience
playing against the best junior girls uh
in the nation you being one of them how
do you feel about it I mean it's really
nice I get to play like a lot of tough
competition like you just said and I
think it's just a really great
experience overall and I'm grateful for
the opportunity and you're also uh
College uh level right at uh at this
point is that correct yeah I'm mentoring
my first year and how do you combine
this uh academic career as well as your
chess career I mean um I've usually been
able to balance it pretty well like get
my schoolwork out of the way like start
like practice chess
um usually I'm able to get that in and
yeah otherwise I mean academics comes
first obviously but I'm usually able to
follow up with enough practice in
between well a big victory for you
Gracie I have to say congratulations
it's been a pleasure to watch uh today's
game guys any questions our uh
congratulations but uh Kate please yeah
I do have a question congratulations
Gracie on a really nice game I always
admire players who you know have a
tournament that's not going their way I
know it's always difficult for me but
they continue fighting and then they
actually make the win so I'm curious how
is your mindset in this tournament to
like with that perseverance that you
don't just resign the game don't just
like play something to make a draw but
you still fight how do you keep that
um I mean like of course I'm obviously
trying to go for the win in each game
and um as you can see it hasn't been
working out that well this tournament
but I just try to keep a fresh
perspective on it um try to win every
game to get like it's a new
um opportunity and go from there yeah I
think that's that's what it's all about
yeah yeah keeping a positive frame of
mind
thank you Gracie good luck tomorrow yeah
good luck in the last round thank you
is like okay I got a reprieve you know
uh exonerated yeah it's crazy it's like
I don't know what am I supposed to do
you see the body language I like this
during the game they don't move one inch
and then during the post more time they
have so much animated yes
and Igor is like what did I miss
like really really close
by the way Carissa did play that move
King to D4 let's jump to it
Bishop D2 C3 Bishop to C1 and King to C4
and with such a passive Bishop
yeah the other one seems to be very
close to
should over yeah can Carissa just try to
trap it yeah King B3 to B7 that's that's
right yeah yeah that was on her agenda
that's definitely a good move but the
problem is this peshki too is uh
vulnerable uh you can slide over and
pick it off and maybe I can continue
with that plan with Bishop B4 King B3
I like that block the that looks nice
too
you can also right like why not let's
push the pawn this should be winning C2
C2 Rook D1 probably of all of these
I'm picking up the pawn I feel like I
with this it's two points
going on here and it's very important
game by the way C2 yeah that crazy night
ending that we were trying to trap the
black king on H4 that was hilarious and
somehow
well white would really like to capture
that pawn on B3 with Knight thinking
like okay finally I have that Advantage
but 94 counter attack very powerful Fork
exactly
by the way I mean I'm gonna play F3
before I play but can I go B2 right now
[Music]
F3
yeah I want to take this Pawn
but then I will go Knight D3
I'll take the night oh I cannot oh oh
okay good morning
I'm getting tired for the players and
becoming the players are not making
blunders they're just so focused it's
very admirable okay I have a lot to
worry we have an espresso coffee machine
that's right across the street it's
called Starbucks
go ahead Christian yes what if we yes
if I go King F5 King F5 okay
right and now I go H4
how is that this
messing up my pawns but I got a lot of
them you do have a lot of them which
kind of worries me
he's showing understands okay all right
V2 on the board okay dicey getting that
okay B2 on the board
really important move yeah the much
desired King takes B2 allows Knight D3
check forking and picking up upon so F3
sets up
King takes B2
okay so
do we like Christian's idea of H4
I think
H4 g h because if I get that F3 Pawn
okay but then let's not go for F3 let's
be subtle let's go King G6 King H1 okay
that makes sense too
right trying to act smart right now eat
this guy eat this guy and then give up
this one for this one let's have a look
can't yeah can it be done can it be done
let's run away with that 96 can it be
done Knight G5
okay
Knight takes H3 Ah that's uh let's go
night day takes H3 I know I know it's
with trembling hands
and now this is one of those study like
positions right you go Knight E4 I go
Knight G4 you go King F4 and
[Music]
but now I have Knight H6 I think ah
Knight H6
I think that should be
that should be okay by the way I'm just
going to refresh my board for just a
moment as we have this King C2 King C2
no F3 I think Jason this is not easy
though guys I spotted H4 and he's trying
to keep his structure intact
uh
interesting
by the way uh Chris is saying Chris bird
the international Arbiter saying come on
guys uh take it to me we got a
tournament going on in the in the Next
Room here very important two games so
the players should not be disturbed and
they're age four yeah uh Arthur had this
up his sleeve that he wanted to play
this move H4 now the question is with my
Pawn on F3
uh
uh should I no I no you're just gonna
take by the way I think Carissa is close
to shall we go there we'll be winning
the game that's
yes I think that one is when we left it
she just played the move C2 so so that
her Rook could come down to the D1
square right here she just played this
move C2 intending Rook to D1 and
promoting the pawn
she liked
yeah and she can just promote the pawn
now unless wait a minute
unless the Rook is swinging across that
would be
that would be very
shocking well first of all it's
karissa's move right I know she probably
will play rookie Rook did you want just
to be I mean I I have root C2 and Rook
F2 whenever you attack my brother ah
okay so I don't have to be that worried
nothing to be worried about at all she
is not she is able to keep the pawn
okay maybe you run with the pawn A5
how close is this
it should it should be easy right and
I'll be should be three yeah yeah he's
an overall comes be right in time
just in the nick of time
and once again uh how important is this
victory for Carissa in terms of the
girls Championship okay for Carissa it's
very important I think she's gonna be
going for a third place maybe tying but
it's really important for Alice Lee
because if zoiting does not win her game
uh does not make a draw loses her game
Alice Lee is the champion of the US
girls juniors absolutely
uh kind of a ironic thing but it was
sort of like a week or so ago the club
had gotten an invitation I think it's uh
Good Morning America show some one of
these morning shows could we have an
interview with Alice Lee no could we
have an interview with Alice Lee after
she wins the tournament well yes
so uh something about that it was in the
air it was written a week ago as we have
the current position
yeah so I'm in Carousel has seven
minutes to calculate whether she wants
to promote immediately or maybe start
with Rook G1 to attack the bishop
I would I would definitely play Rook G1
myself knowing that I was going to play
The Rook next move but you know
sometimes you know your opponent puts
the bishop on the wrong Square then
you've got to check and you could take
it or something of that nature so yeah I
would I would definitely test my
opponent first with the move Rook G1
plus you get 30 seconds plus you get 30
seconds and no harm no no follow it
right
is very focused because she kind of
feels she's close to winning that game
but accuracy still matters very much
she doesn't want to to miss those good
moves for sure
and she needs this Victory she's been
having a rock event yeah well that loss
to Alice Lee and I really I it it
confounded me so much like the players I
imagine I went back and uh studied it
with the engine just to understand and
Carissa was winning in that game she she
she could have upset Alice at one moment
and then she's a shot she had a lot of
chances to make a draw but Carissa was
saying she really wanted to play for win
and she just over pushed exactly that
those losses hurt those are the ones
that really really do hurt
Zoe has been stowing throughout this
whole game and she's just you know very
composed really she has a repressive
poker face right that is for sure
there was an Armenian player the pooch
the Putin simbot the putian and he would
sit there at the board you know very
stoically with his hands together and
just not move he had the greatest
sits flesh in the world only him and
Archer yusupov were true competitors and
sits fleisch and I think we have who
Brandon Jacobson host like made a
mistake and then he was like I just had
to remain calm for a little bit
otherwise we see the C1 uh promotion yes
uh Carissa didn't take my advice and up
for Rook G1 she went right for it we're
expecting Rook F7 and then oops excuse
me that was my mouse slip Rook F7 and
then Carissa will have to find brook
after Rook C2 check and oh
she she definitely found it already
when she promoted yes yes otherwise she
wouldn't have promoted
by the way but I feel like Zoe forgot to
push clock
right or no it's always turn okay it's
always turn oh I got worried to be very
uncomfortable
that was a very very famous moment in
one of the kaspar of karpov match
clashes Kasparov just forgot to press
his clock and he had like four or five
minutes and uh Anatoly just sat at the
board and you know pretended to be
thinking and spiroff looked at the clock
in horror he gonna smashed the clock
like hey man it's your responsibility to
press the cloth I don't have to remind
you exactly
and Rook check this was this was the the
key move that she could play Rook F2 and
the thing is if you drop back let's say
to E1 I can even go King D3 not worry
about ah check me right now
oh I really like that move not even
hesitating
was ready to play Rook F2 regardless I
don't care what you do I'm gonna play
Rook up too uh but King D3
that was a very nice move by the way Zoe
it's a freak now Rook C7 she's trying to
capture that Bishop on C5 so then the
Rook on F2 is up for grabs the last
trick in the position
Last Chance Saloon right here and you
know you play for three hours it's very
easy to make a Blog but Karissa sees
that yes
moving The Rook away
yep
A5 King B5 King David five yes yes
getting out of the PIN
be prepping Rook A4 and
then F4 and I think Zoe will give it a
rest I mean she can probably play King
B5 as well right yeah also okay yep
I think right now Carissa knows it's
just uh
a technical task an easy technical task
for a player of her caliber
um
by the way any takers from Rook E4 check
and Rook E7
[Laughter]
but wait is it such is it
a test we can expect A6 A6 Rook A5 and
Rook A4 sorry F4
and then the next turn we just make sure
we now blunder the bond we go Bishop E3
right just to be double double because
if I go King E2 now this
so now at long last I'm ready to capture
the path
the vultures okay vultures you guys are
the vultures right
that's us that's us
so should we move yeah let's take a look
at the last game in the Juniors
oh this one is yes
he looks like he's doing it he's done it
uh wow very lust wow half a point
he's done it
and by the way if you go Knight to G6
perhaps the easy way is to just go King
G4 King F5
I'll give you the Knight
I go to uh
to pick up your night
wow
I give nothing I would never
you've never had a thing you move your
night Knight G6 I'm going night at three
yeah afternoon I'm very happy about this
safe wow oh yes yes he is
no I mean look well deserved he was
exactly on the back foot the whole game
really the whole game starting from the
opening phase by the way even if Jason
lose time right this is a draw
I don't I don't think so there's mating
material on the board I can meet you
with a knight yes I can set up a
position in which I made you and that
means that you missed the game so I mean
it's like weird I mean I wouldn't risk
it right right right right right right
okay so
he has to make a move he has 25 seconds
as you prescribed it yeah
so now I think he's gonna go in King G4
yeah I would play 903 but uh I do admire
your your willingness to part with
material
it doesn't come lightly but
right if you know your key squares you
have them it is a technical end game yes
he's thinking about it I can I can sense
I trust my wheels are turning
actually there is another funny way of
doing it and that is Knight F1 because
F5 does allow Knight E3 and we're ready
to Fork
that Knight G6 I would play Knight F3
personally
yes yes
[Music]
showing Yasser why he's wrong
but Christian are impressed that you
chose this move given in medic's game
you are really against King C7
well
no no no
no they're not comparable look I sense
these moments
I can read my uh my guys right Arthur is
not my guys by the way for Jason I mean
he's a moral Victor I was up at night in
a pond yeah in the ending it was just a
capturing that night
too bad that I couldn't win with a knife
King F6 no your end games no hear it
keeping the he squares G6 F6
E6
now the defense always looking behind
the pawn keep it there as long as
possible
now go to opposition top position yes
most important thing in King opponent
games
distant opposition
and and now Arthur the only one move
makes a draw everything else loses you
have to go under the pawn he's making
sure everything is good yeah
you're gonna see stalemate very soon
he's not a GM elect for no reason you're
right
by the way as this game just about to
end right here right now in stalemate
and to draw our congratulations to
Arthur Carissa has won and we can
announce that Alice Lee we have the U.S
girls junior Champion Alice Lee our
congratulations to Alice fantastic
wow here we go feed a master actually
also International Master elect Alice
Lee the 2023 U.S junior girls Champion
congratulations fantastic performance
with round to spare already having the
title and she also wins six thousand
dollars and the scholarships
generation and the Dwayne Barber
Foundation well done Alice and the US
Championship well she was going to
qualify by rating for sure but uh
nonetheless hey don't spoil the parties
and it it's a very very prestigious
invitation I tell you wow well that's
all right here we go here we go you
asked her a good job I know I mean we
need more competition
so you predicted even though we're the
best Authority you know we're caught the
pressure yeah
wow
check it out still in it yeah check it
out I kind of okay okay this is what
matters
the experience yeah the experienced
championship this is the one big
congratulations to Malik's winning
Christian Vegas that was a that was an
insightful and insightful choice I have
to say I didn't see that coming but
Christian some of this penultimate round
just an incredible a day of Chess we
crowned two Victors two new Champions
here in St Louis is what we do what we
love to do here in St Louis Crown
Champions with crown 2 today and we will
Crown another one either tomorrow or
maybe during the tie breaks After
Tomorrow still a lot of Chess to be
played still a lot of exciting games to
be played and we will be calling all the
action from the studio here in St Louis
we will see you tomorrow guys absolutely
Christian that's the way we feel once
again great calling reaction with UK
it's been a lot of fun hope you've
enjoyed yourself uh for a decisive just
you certainly came to the right show and
we'll say good night join us tomorrow
for round nine
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited